THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELL IT-
CONFERENCE PARTICIPATION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE-
A SERVICE TO PARTICIPATION TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
- IT SHOULD BE DISPLAYED ON. THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPATION NUMBER
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
FOURTEEN. ONE ONE ONE FORTY I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
COMPETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE-
STREET BUILDING I ASKED ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE- TO
PLEASE COME TO ROOM. TWELVE
HUNDRED- SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BEGIN OUR HEARING. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE THE HAND. FEATURE IN YOUR
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU'LL BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD. LIKE TO BE ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT THAT MEET BEFORE YOU
BEGINSPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT WE- ARE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME. AND THEN WE'RE READY
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE I TELL ALL THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVEN'T MET SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. WE USED A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL%
DISCUSSION ITEMS TO BE BEEN
PRESENTED. GOOD MORNING SENATE
MCGUIRE WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM OF. A QUORUM
SO WE'LL WAIT NOW WITH REGARD TO
THE CALENDAR. PLEASE NOTE THAT-
ARE VOTE OLD ONLY CALENDAR-
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN SANTA. SANTA
SUSANA FIELD LAB CLEANUP TEAM
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
CALENDAR WILL BE RESCHEDULED AT
ANOTHER TIME THAT SANTA SUSANNA. ON ISSUE NUMBER- SEVEN. OKAY
SO ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS WHO
OTHER THAN ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
OTHER ANY OF VOTE ONLY ITEMS AT
ANY MEMBERS WITH ELECTED- PULL
FROM THE- THE- K. VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR SEEING NONE WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH
IS THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE
BOARD. OIL AND GAS AND FORSMAN
COMMUNITY PROTECTION- MISS
QUIROZ FROM- ASSISTANT DIVISION
CHIEF OF ENFORCEMENT DIVISION IS
HERE OF. PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU- AGAIN MY NAME
IS HEATHER HEROES I AM THE
ASSISTANT DIVISION CHIEF FOR
CARBS ENFORCEMENT DIVISION AND
I'M GOING TO DISCUSS OUR
PROPOSAL FOR OIL AND GAS AND
FORSMAN AND COMMUNITY PROTECTION
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS REQUESTING A TOTAL OF
SIX PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS INITIATIVE THREE
OF THE NEW POSITIONS AS WELL AS
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR IN
CONTRACT FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR
STAFF TRAINING TO FOCUS
EXCLUSIVELY ON IMPLEMENTING THE
INITIATIVE AT OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THESE POSITIONS AND
CONTRACT DOLLARS WILL BE FUNDED
BY THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND AT AN ANNUAL
COST OF SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THE OTHER
THREE NEW POSITIONS WILL FOCUS
ON IMPLEMENTING THE INITIATIVE
AT OIL AND GAS IMPORTATION
REFINING AND DISTRIBUTION
FACILITIES THESE POSITIONS WILL
BE FUNDED BY THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND AT AN ANNUAL COST
OF SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. CARBS THE
FORTY AND RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
DIRECTLY REGULATE AND ENFORCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SOURCES
FROM OIL AND GAS FACILITIES.
INCLUDING METHANE EMISSIONS AS
PART OF CARDS METHANE EMISSION
CONTROL WILL. AND TO SUPPORT AND
OVERSEE AIR DISTRICTS EMISSION
REDUCTION REGULATORY PERMITTING
AND ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS. LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR REGULATING CRITERIA
POLLUTANT EMISSIONS FROM OIL AND
GAS WELLS. AND THEN CAL JAM
REGULATES THE EXTRACTION OF OIL
AND GAS FROM WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
. THE PURPOSE OF THIS B. C. P.
S. TO A FAST OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES COMPLIANCE WITH AIR
QUALITY REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH CARDS OVERSIGHT
ROLE. IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FORMAL COMPLAINTS RECEIVED BY
CARD FROM LOCALS INCLUDING THOSE
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND TO COLLABORATE WITH THEIR
DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
AIR REGULATIONS ARE DELIVERING
ON THEIR PURPOSE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS INITIATIVE
WILL INCLUDE REGULAR INSPECTIONS
AND REVISION I'M SORRY AND
REVIEWS AT THESE FACILITIES.
ALLOWING CARP STAFF IN
CONSULTATION WITH RELEVANT
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO PRODUCE
SUMMARY REPORTS THAT DETAIL
COMPLIANCE STATUS. MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PROGRAMMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS AND IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADDITIONAL
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. TO CLARIFY
THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW PROGRAM BUT
IS A REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT STAFF TO ADDRESS THE
NEED AND OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NOT COVERED BY EXISTING
RESOURCES. ARD CURRENTLY HAS
ONE POSITION RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCEMENT AT WELLING GAS
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE BUT
ONE PERSON IS NOT ENOUGH TO DO
THE ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT AND
OVERSIGHT WORK NEEDED TO
EVALUATE COMPLIANCE ENSURE
CONSISTENT AND ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT OF AIR QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS AND HELP IMPROVE
PROGRAMS AS NEEDED. TO ENSURE
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION GOALS
ARE ACHIEVED. EXAMPLES OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS INCLUDE CARBS
STUDY OF NEIGHBORHOOD AIR NEAR
PETROLEUM SOURCES WERE SNAPPED
WHICH CHARACTERIZES THE AIR
QUALITY IN COMMUNITIES NEAR OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION FACILITIES
AND INCLUDES A HEALTH ASSESSMENT
CONDUCTED BY- WE HA. ALSO CARDS
COMMUNITY ARE PROTECTION
PROGRAM- FOCUSES ON REDUCING
EXPOSURE IN COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY AIR POLLUTION.
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT NEW STRATEGIES TO
MEASURE AIR POLLUTION AND
REDUCED HEALTH IMPACTS. THIS
FIRST OF ITS KIND STATEWIDE
EFFORT INCLUDES COMMUNITY AIR
MONITORING AND COMMUNITY
EMISSIONS REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
APPROVING THIS PROPOSAL WILL
HELP KERR BETTER UNDERSTAND AND
ADDRESS THE COMPLAINTS CARP IS
RECEIVING ABOUT OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES AS WELL AS INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY TO HELP BUILD TRUST
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES AND AIR
QUALITY REGULATORS. THE RESULTS
OF REPORTS REVIEWS AND
INSPECTIONS FROM THIS PROGRAM
WILL HELP TO DIRECTLY ADDRESS AT
THE FACILITY LEVEL ANY POTENTIAL
EMISSIONS SOURCES IDENTIFIED
THROUGH MONITORING AND CONCERNS
RAISED TO CARVE THROUGH
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. TO PAINT A
PICTURE OF WHAT THIS WOULD LOOK
LIKE HARDSTAFF RECENTLY
CONDUCTED JOINT INSPECTIONS WITH
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS STOP IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND FOR OIL
AND GAS FIELDS NEAR THE CITIES
THESE INSPECTIONS CARP STAFF
NOTED THREE WEEKS IN EXCESS OF
ONE THOUSAND PARTS PER MILLION
METHANE AND IDENTIFIED EQUIPMENT
OPERATING ON SITE THAT WAS NOT
COVERED BY LOCAL DISTRICT
PERMIT. CARDSTOCK FOR THESE
ISSUES TO THE LOCAL DISTRICT WHO
ISSUED A NOTICE OF VIOLATION. TO
BE CLEAR CARP IS NOT SEEN THE
DISTRICTS ARE NOT DOING THEIR
JOBS CARP AND THE DISTRICTS HAVE
SEPARATE RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE PROPERLY
ENFORCED. AND CARD HAS A
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE
DISTRICTS IN THEIR WORK. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE NEEDED
RESOURCES TO INCREASE OUR
ENFORCEMENT CAPABILITIES IN
ORDER TO SERVE AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS. FROM HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION BY ENSURING THAT STATE
AND LOCAL POLICIES ARE
DELIVERING BENEFITS AS THEY WERE
INTENDED TO. THANK YOU AND I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. DON'T GO
ANYWHERE BECAUSE I'M SURE WE
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS SO. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
HISTORICALLY TRADITIONALLY. WE
HAVE THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
DEAL WITH STATIONERY'S
POLLUTANTS. IN THE OF. CARBON
HERE IN SACRAMENTO DEALS WITH
MOBILE OF POLLUTANTS CAN YOU.
TO THE- REQUESTS FOR THE SIX
ADDITIONAL STEPS. YEAH HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- SO WE DO HAVE
SOME COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL I
THINK FIRST OFF OVERALL WE THINK
THAT ENSURING THE BOARD HAS
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO MONITOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REGULATIONS
THAT ARE INTENDED TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION PARTICULARLY IN
HEAVILY POLLUTED COMMUNITIES HAS
MERIT. SO WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE UNDERLYING GOALS THE
CARDS TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. HOWEVER WE DO
THINK THE PROPOSAL RAISES SOME
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER-
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO
PRIORITIZING RESOURCES WHY
EXISTING RESOURCES ARE
INSUFFICIENT CHEN. AS THE
TERMINATIONS OR WHO SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE EFFORTS WE
HAVE THREE MAIN SETS OF
QUESTIONS THAT WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE COMMITTEE
ASKING MINISTRATIONS REPORT AT
AND IN THIS HEARING AND SO THE
FIRST IS. WHY SHOULD THE STATE
FOCUS OF LIMITED RESOURCES ON
MONITORING OF OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION FACILITIES RATHER
THAN OTHER SOURCES OF POLLUTION
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN MANY HEAVILY
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES MOBILE
SOURCES SUCH AS DIESEL TRUCKS
AND EQUIPMENT ARE THE PRIMARY
SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION AND SO.
WE THINK ONE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
BUT AS THE ADMINISTRATION- ONE
KIND OF FOCUS ON OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES HAS SUCH A HIGH
PRIORITY. THE SECOND- QUESTION
WE THINK IT IS- WIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES NEEDED- AND- AS AS THE
BOARD MENTIONED IN ITS- INITIAL
COMMENTS CAR PARTY HAS SOME
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND STAFF
RESOURCES DEDICATED TO SOME
SIMILAR ACTIVITIES SO FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING THE
STUDY OF NEIGHBORHOOD ERROR-
NEAR PETROLEUM SOURCES- BUT
WHICH SAID THE BOARD MENTIONED
IN ITS COMMENTS AS WELL AS
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN ACTIVITIES
AND OTHER RESEARCH EFFORTS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND EMISSIONS
FROM. FACILITIES THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO ASK CARGO EXPLAIN
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHY
THOSE EXISTING RESOURCES ARE
INSUFFICIENT- TO MEET ITS GOALS-
AND THEN FINALLY IT- TO GET TO
THE POINT THAT THE CHAIR JUST
MENTIONED WHY CARBS SO IF EVEN.
IF MORE RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO
PROVIDE. OVERSIGHT OF OIL GAS.
IN THE- WHY IS CARBON ENERGY
CONDUCT EFFORTS- GEN LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS TO HAVE THE- WERE. FOR
READ. STATIONARY OF POLLUTION.
INCLUDING OIL AND IS STILL AND
SO FAR MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED A
CAR BROTHER THEN LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS SO THAT IT WAS KIND OF
OUR OUR COMMENTS ON THE-
PROPOSAL SOME OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO. EXPLORE DURING
THE HEARING AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU UP SOME MISTER
BROWN. THE LOCAL DISTRICT HAS
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
THESE OIL FACILITIES AND WE
HEARD THE TESTIMONY THAT THE
CARB. DILLON RIGHT ALONG OR GET
IT TO IN. THAT DAY THAT THE-
WENT WITH THE LOCAL ARTISTIC IS.
ARE THEY SAYING THAT THEY ONE
THEY FOUND THIS WEEK THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE ONLY FOUND IT BECAUSE
CARP WAS THERE IN THE LOCAL AIR.
DISTRICT WOULDN'T FOUND THAT WE
COULD YOU HAVE YOU HAVE ANY. ANY
EVIDENCE OR ANY INFORMATION THAT
THAT THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
AREN'T DOING THEIR JOB ON
REGULAR LEAKS THAT THEY WITH
FINE. I MEAN I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A- CLEAR
ANSWER TO- THE POINT YOU'RE JUST
MAKING IT'S NOT CLEAR WHETHER
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS WHATEVER
KIND OF IDENTIFIED THAT. WEEK
ANYWAYS AND TRY TO ADDRESS IT
AND SO IT'S SORT OF THE- H. ARE
A MAGNITUDE OF KIND OF DIFFERENT
PROBLEM I THINK THAT IT'S KIND
OF A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT FOR US
TO. TO KIND OF WRAP HER HEAD
AROUND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
EVIDENCE THAT. HE'S SAYING THAT
THE WORKERS ARE SO FAR I'M
KINDA. IT IS A- BIG PROBLEM AT
THIS POINT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE BUT I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF AN ISSUE THAT WE
I THINK DON'T HAVE A LOT OF GOOD
INFORMATION. RIGHT NOW IN THIS
PCP IN FRONT OF YOU DO YOU SEE
IT AS DUPLICATIVE. ARE YOU IS IT
CLEAR TO YOU THAT IT'S A GOOD
DUPLICATIVE INSPECTIONS THAT
THEY COULD DO THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO- OR IS IT COULD BE
INDEPENDENT. INSPECTIONS AS A
GOOD U. S. STATIONARY SOURCES.
WHICH IS LIKE THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SOME OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY BUT THEY WOULD DO
THE INSPECTION. OR SET UNCLEAR
TO YOU. THAT'S NOT TOTALLY CLEAR
I THINK THE WAY. THAT- WE HAVE
UNDERSTOOD IT IS THAT THAT- IT
WOULD BE SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
WHERE THE PARK STAFF WAS KIND OF
GO ALONG WITH THEIR DISTRICT
STAFF TO KIND OF MONITOR- ANY
KIND OF CONDUCT INSPECTIONS
ALTHOUGH BUT- YOU KNOW AND
THAT'S A QUESTION YOU MIGHT WANT
TO ASK THE BOARD JUST TO CLARIFY
EXACTLY KIND OF THAT YOU KNOW
PRACTICE GOING TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR. YOU AND
JUST THAT'S WHERE I'M GOING MR
OCULAR- AT FINANCE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE THAT QUESTION OR DO
YOU HAVE- WOULD YOU LIKE. TO GO
BACK TO MISS QUIROZ. FINANCE YOU
AIR YEAH YEAH GOOD MORNING GREAT
AMERICA FROM THEIR FORMER
FINANCE HOW WE ARE GOING TO-
TURN THAT QUESTION OVER TO COURT
. SIX HE UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION
YOU WERE WE ARE WE GET THAT THIS
IS. ALLEGEDLY NOT A NEW PROGRAM
AND THAT IT SAY YOU WERE DOING A
JOINT INSPECTION AND ARE YOU I
GUESS ARE YOU SAYING THAT
FINDING THESE LEAKS WAS ONLY
BECAUSE DUE TO CARP STAFF OR WAS
THAT. JOINTLY DISCOVERED. IT'S
NOT A QUESTION FOR ME YES YES
YES I'M NO I'M NOT WE'RE NOT
MISS IT SO THE WAY THAT THE WAY
THAT IT WORKS SO THE DISTRICT
HAS PRIMARY FORTY OVER CERTAIN
POLLUTANTS- CARB HAS
RESPONSIBILITY TO REGULATE
GREENHOUSE GAS POLLUTANTS WHICH
IS PRIMARILY METHANE FROM THE
SOURCES- AND SO- AND THEN WE
ALSO DELEGATE SOME OF THE A
FORTY TWO AND FOUR STAR RANK TO
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS BUT NOT ALL
THAT FAIR DISTRICTS DO THAT- AND
SO WE ARE OUT AND HAVE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ENFORCING OUR
METHANE RULE- THE DISTRICTS ARE
OUT AT THESE FACILITIES AND
FORCING THEIR OWN REGULATIONS-
F. AND THEN SO IF WE GO OUT WE
OFTEN GO WITH THE DISTRICT.
WE'RE BOTH KIND OF LOOKING FOR
DIFFERENT THINGS- IF THE
DISTRICT HAS DELEGATED AUTHORITY
IF YOU'RE AN EMPLOYER YOU TO
ALSO LOOK AT THE METHANE RULE
WERE OUT THERE ARE OUT THERE
WITH- ENSURING THAT WERE IN THE
LOOP IN TERMS OF ON WHAT WE'RE
FINDING- YOU KNOW ENSURING THAT
WERE ALL CONSISTENT AND HOW WERE
IN FORCE IN THE RAKES AND
IDENTIFY IN THE WEEKS- IF WE
IDENTIFY LEAKS THAT ARE WITHIN
THE DISTRICT'S PURVIEW THEN WE
LET THEM KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE FOUND AND THEY FOLLOW UP AND
PURSUE WHATEVER ACTION IS
NEEDED. SO GOING IF THIS
PROPOSAL IS APPROVED YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT YOUR STAFF WILL
BE DOING THESE INSPECTIONS
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE AIR
DISTRICTS WE DO THEM SOMETIMES
INDEPENDENTLY- IF FOR EXAMPLE A
DISTRICTS NOT ABLE TO JOIN US
AND WE DO REACH OUT TO THE
DISTRICTS EVERY TIME WE'RE GOING
OUT TO A SITE TO LET THEM KNOW
WE'RE GOING AND INVITE THEM TO
COME ALONG WITH US SO WE'LL GET
TO THE HUNDRED SEVENTY
COMPLAINTS YOU KNOW WE RECEIVED
A REPORT THAT TALKED ABOUT
NOTHING AND THAT AND THE
CHALLENGE WITH MATH AND WE KNOW
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
WHOLE WORLD IS TRYING TO DO A
LOT ABOUT METHANE. AND WE HEARD
WE WERE LOOKING AT GAS
FACILITIES AND WILL FACILITIES
TRANSPORTATION AND IT WAS LIKE
THREE OR 4% OF THIS OF THE
STATE'S METHANE IS FROM. LEAKS
AND THEN CITY 6% OF. PER IS FROM
LIKE. AND THINGS LIKE TO. SO
JUST FOOD FOR THOUGHT I'M
CURIOUS BECAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING COME OUT FROM CARP. ON
VERY TIGHT GESTURES OR AMP IN
THE AGRICULTURAL NOTHING ON
LANDFILLS WHICH ARE A BIG SOURCE
NOTHING ON FORGET PICKS THAT ARE
ARE. ARE CREATING METHANE
ABSOLUTE QUIET BUT THAT ON THIS
SMALL LITTLE. 4% FOR OIL LEAKS-
WE GOT A WHOLE A WHOLE NEW
PROGRAM SO I JUST PUT THAT OUT
THERE TO GIVE SOME TEXTURE TO.
THAT THE BIGGER PICTURE- SO WHEN
YOU RECEIVE COMPLAINTS HE SAID
YOU THE TESTIFIED THAT YOU CAN
YOU GET. YOUR RECEIVE A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS A HUNDRED SEVENTY
PEOPLE- THESE ARE DIFFERENT FROM
THE FROM- THE RIGHT ALONG WHEN
YOU WRITE THAT THAT WAS THAT YOU
JUST YOU GOT SOME INFORMATION.
BY WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE
COMPLAINTS RIGHT NOW ARE THE
COMPLAINTS DO YOU. TOSS THEM OR
PASS THEM ON TO THE AIR DISTRICT
WHEN SOMEBODY COME CALLS UP
WERE- WITH THIS ONE PERSON THAT
GETS TO RECEIVE SOME WHAT
HAPPENS. BUT WE DO REFER
COMPLAINTS THAT WE GET TO THEIR
DISTRICTS- AND AGAIN WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON- DEDICATED TO OIL AND
GAS AND FORSMAN AND SO THEY DO
THEIR BEST TO INVESTIGATE. BUT
WITH THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
THAT WERE RECEIVING- WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO AT THIS
MOMENT- TO INVESTIGATE IN DEPTH.
ALL OF THEM- AND TO TRY TO
DETERMINE WHY WE ARE RECEIVING
THESE COMPLAINTS. BECAUSE RIGHT
WELL. IT I GUESS THE QUESTION OF
THE FOLLOW UP IS THAT IF YOU.
YOU SAID THAT THE- DISTRICT YOU
DON'T YOU'RE NOT IN THE CAME
THAT THE OR DISTRICTS ARE DOING
THEIR JOBS BUT IF YOU GIVE THEM
THESE COMPLAINTS TODAY DID YOU
GET SOME REPORT BACK THAT IT'S
BEEN REMEDIED OR ANYTHING LIKE
OUT OF THE OF OR SOME
INVESTIGATION OR SOMETHING WE
KNOW ABOUT THIS MORE WORKING ON
IT. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE. WE DO COORDINATE
WITH THEIR DISTRICTS WE DO ALSO
STILL RECEIVE COMPLAINTS FROM
COMMUNITIES. SO. THE NEW STAFF
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING. HOW MANY
OF THOSE COMPLAINTS DO YOU THINK
ARE GOING TO BE ACTION THAT YOU
GUYS TO GET A TAKE VERSUS VERSUS
GETTING MORE INFORMATION TO THE
MAKING SURE THEY ALL GET PASSED
ON TO THE AIRPORTS THE LOCAL
AIRPORTS I MEAN WHAT. WHAT IS IT
THAT YOUR STAFF IS GOING TO DO.
SO I THINK WE INTO YOUR INITIAL
QUESTION I THINK IT'S HARD TO
KNOW- BECAUSE WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO. SORT OF DIVING A LITTLE
DEEPER TO FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE ISSUES ARE- AND WHY
WE'RE RECEIVING ALL OF THESE
COMPLAINTS- BUT WHAT WE WOULD BE
DOING IS. THE COMPLAINTS THAT WE
RECEIVE WE WOULD INVESTIGATE WE
WOULD DO INSPECTIONS WE WOULD
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH OUR
REGULATIONS AND ENSURE
COMPLIANCE YOU KNOW COORDINATE
WITH THE DISTRICTS. ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH LOCAL DISTRICT
REGULATIONS- PURSUANT TO OUR
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. REVIEWING
DISTRICT PROGRAMS AND PERMITS
AND MAKING SURE THAT- YOU KNOW
THAT ALL OF THE AIR QUALITY
REGULATIONS ARE ARE SORT OF
HEALTH PROTECTIVE AND MEETING
OUR AIR QUALITY GOALS. NOW DO
YOU ANTICIPATE THAT THIS STAFF
WILL BE IN SACRAMENTO WHERE THEY
GET TO BE IN THE VICINITY OF
THESE OIL. FACILITIES THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION I. PROBABLY IN
BOTH OKAY WE HAVE A SACRAMENT WE
HAVE A STOMACH CAL LOCATION SO I
THINK BEING IN BOTH LOCATIONS
AND BEING ABLE TO SORT OF-
EASILY ACCESS AND GET TO THOSE
LOCATIONS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
WOULD BE IDEAL. AND OUR IS THE
TASK INCLUDING AN OVERSIGHT OF
THE INSPECTIONS AT THE LOCAL M.
DISTRICTS ARE CURRENTLY DOING
NOW WE'RE SYSTEM TOTALLY COULD
BE INDEPENDENT AS PART OF AS YOU
CALL IT YOUR OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
. IS IT ART ARE SOME OF THE DO
YOU ANTICIPATE THAT THE CARB
STAFF IS GOING TO BE TAGGING
ALONG WITH THE LOCAL INSPECTIONS
WHEN THEY DO THEIR THEIR
INSPECTION- AS PART OF YOUR
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OR YOU GOING
TO DO BROWN I GUESS IT BE MORE
AKIN TO AN AUDIT THAT YOU'RE
GOOD TO GO IN AND INDEPENDENTLY
WITH CARB STAFF. LOOK FOR THESE-
LEAKS AND OF ANSWER THESE
COMPLAINTS. WHEN THE WHEN IT
INVOLVES THE DEBT PRIMARILY WE
WOULD BE COORDINATING WITH THE
DISTRICTS- AND GOING WITH THEM
ON INSPECTIONS THERE MAY BE SOME
LOCATIONS WHERE FOR EXAMPLE
pDIRECT ENFORCEMENT OF OUR ON
METHANE RULE- AND AGAIN IN THOSE
INSTANCES WE- YOU KNOW. ALWAYS
LET THE DISTRICTS KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING OUT ON SITE AND
INVITE THEM TO COME ALONG- BUT
IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO OR YOU
KNOW WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE WE
COULD POTENTIALLY BE GOING ON
OUR OWN AS WELL. BUT WE DO
ALWAYS CREAMY WITH THE DISTRICTS
SUMMER THE DON'T YOU HAVE
ENFORCEMENT STAFF TO- ASSIGNED
TO THE AB SIX ONE SEVEN PROGRAM
- BUT WE DO HAVE STAFF THAT
COORDINATE WITH THE SIX ONE
SEVEN BUT IT'S SORT OF A BILL
RELATED. CURRENTLY WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT THAT WE DO ON ON
MOBILE SOURCES- AND WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES WE HAVE
THE ONE THE ONE P. Y. ON THE OIL
AND GAS. SO IT'S YOU IT'S YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
CANNOT BE USED TO SPOT
INSPECTIONS AT THE SPOIL.
FACILITIES RIGHT. THEY CAN'T GET
NOW NONE OF THEM ARE AVAILABLE
THAT'S THAT'S- BEYOND THEIR
ABILITY OR IS IT WORSE HE JUST
BEYOND THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
TIME. THEY'RE THEY'RE FUNDED TO
DO- MOBILE SOURCE INSPECTIONS
AND SO ABOUT IS THEIR THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY IN WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT THEY'RE USED FOR YEAH
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE'S A
THERE'S A FLAVOR OF MISSION
CREEP HERE THAT THAT. YOU WE'RE
YOU'RE ALLEGING THAT ITS
OVERSIGHT BUT THEN IT'S ACTUALLY
DOING THE WORK THAT THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WOULD DO THAT WE
HAVE THE SEPARATION WITH THE
HERE WITH THAT IT LOCAL AIRPORTS
IN CARBS SO- THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE'LL PAUSE. AND I WILL. ASK
MISS ROY TO CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WHY CASKEY
HERE I KASKY HERE DOLLY DOLLY
HERE MCGUIRE. STERN HERE RIGHT
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM-
CENTER STONE YOUR QUESTION.
COMING INTO QUESTION- BEEN
LISTENING TO THE COLLOQUY HERE
AND I GUESS EIGHT. TAKE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VIEW I'M I'M
I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED HE JUST
SPENT THE LAST FIFTEEN MINUTES
QUESTIONING. ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE OIL
AND GAS OVERSIGHT WHEN THERE'S
THAT ONE OFFICIAL WORKING AT THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD TO OVERSEE THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY. ENFORCING A METHANE
RULE- THAT IS WOEFULLY UNDER
ENFORCED AND- EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT THE AIR DISTRICTS AREN'T
GETTING THE JOB DONE ON THEIR
OWN- POLLUTION RULES BEEN
REJECTED BY THE EPA RECENTLY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND TO CALL
IT ANYTHING TO CALL IT SMALL IN
A QUIET AND SMALL ISSUE- MEANS
THAT YOU'VE NEVER SEEN WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO HAVE A LEASE SO CANYON
GO POISON TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE OR
EVEN ALL OF SANTA MONICA BE SHUT
DOWN YESTERDAY FOR TWELVE HOURS
BECAUSE- THERE'S A MASSIVE
GHASTLY- THIS IS HAPPENING ALL
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH PLAN IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND IT MAY NOT BE
A- BIG OF A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ISSUE. BUT IT IS ANYTHING BUT
SMALL AND QUIET IN LA WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF SITES THAT
DESPERATELY ARE IN NEED OF
INSPECTION THAT THERE WOEFULLY
UNDER EQUIPPED. EITHER UNWILLING
OR UNABLE TO INSPECT THESE
SITES. AND I'M YOU KNOW I MIGHT
MIGHT MY QUESTION OR MY CONCERN
IS THAT THIS IS NOT ENOUGH. I DO
THINK THAT THE AIRPORT IS GOING
TO HAVE TO TAKE SOME SEMI
INDEPENDENT. LEADERSHIP HERE IN.
ADDRESSING THE GREENHOUSE GAS
SIDE OF THESE FACILITIES
THEMSELVES BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT
HAPPENING- THERE ARE THERE'S
METHANE LEAKING IN A PLUME ALL
OVER. LOS ANGELES AND THE SOUTH
COAST IS NOT BEEN ABLE TO TELL
US WHY. INITIAL ESTIMATES FROM
BOTH NASA AND UCLA HAVE SHOWN
THAT THERE IS AN ACCUMULATION OF
LEAKS FROM- THOUSANDS OF
ABANDONED OR IDLE OIL AND GAS
AND IT'S ALL OVER LA SO. THE
NOTION OF PUSHING BACK ON A
MILLION SEVEN WHEN WE'VE GOT A
FORTY OR MILLION FOR WHEN WE'VE
GOT A FORTY BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUS ON OUR HANDS
SEEMS TO ME. A LITTLE BIT
MISSING THE BURNING FOREST FOR A
TREAT- I WOULD JUST ASK THE
AIRBOARD- IN IN LOS ANGELES
ALONE. HOW MANY SITES DO YOU
ANTICIPATE I MEAN IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT THE OVERALL METHANE
FOOTPRINT OF A PLACE LIKE THAT
WHERE. IT'S NOT JUST REFINING
BUT LEGACY OIL AND GAS WELLS.
HOW MUCH OF THAT WORKLOAD DO YOU
THINK THIS. MODEST REQUEST IS
GOING TO COVER. I YEAH I DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER ON THAT-
BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY- SEVERAL
SITES IN THAT REGION AND OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT WILL BE
FOCUSING ON- I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBER FOR THAT. HOW MANY
SITES DO YOU KNOW TOTAL NOT HOW
MANY THIS WILL COVER BUT HOW
MANY SITES. ARE THERE IN SAY THE
STATE OVERALL THAT ARE THE
TARGET OF THE METHANE RULE. FOR
OIL AND GAS. I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU I'M NOT- I DON'T HAVE THAT
DIDN'T HUNDREDS OR IS IT IN THE
THOUSANDS WHAT WOULD YOU SAY. DO
IF IT'S OKAY CAN I CAN I GET
BACK TO YOU I'M I'M GONNA SAY
THOUSANDS- BUT I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBER OFF HAND. OKAY ENDS
AND IN TERMS OF THE ABILITY TO
MONITOR- MONITOR THESE SITES I
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S A
PUBLIC HEALTH RULE ALSO PENDING
BEFORE CAL JIM WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING IN OVERSEEING THAT ISSUE
IN TERMS OF NEIGHBORHOOD OIL AND
GAS DRILLING- WITH THE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE. IS
YOUR IS YOUR INTENTION HERE THAT
- THAT THESE KIND OF THIS KIND
OF ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITY
PROTECTION COULD DOVE TAIL WITH
OVERALL ENHANCED MONITORING AND
ENFORCEMENT REQUIREMENTS AROUND
PUBLIC HEALTH WHEN IT COMES TO
NEIGHBORHOOD OIL AND GAS
DRILLING. YES I DO THINK THAT-
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS SORT OF
COORDINATE AND- OUR PLAN IS TO
COORDINATE WITH ALL- RELEVANT
AGENCIES INVOLVED- WITH THESE
FACILITIES OKAY WELL IF YOU
COULD JUST GET BACK TO US I
THINK IT BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW MUCH OF THE- HOW MUCH. OF
THE STATE GOES ON INSPECTED
RIGHT NOW. AND WHAT YOU THINK
THIS THE SIX POSITIONS COULD
COVER IN TERMS OF THAT TOTAL
WORKLOAD I THINK THAT WOULD HELP
WHILE. IF WE HOLD THIS OPEN
TODAY ESPECIALLY TO MAKE A- A
LITTLE STRONGER AND WELL
PREPARED BETTER WELL PREPARED
CASE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
BECAUSE I THINK THERE IS A
STRONG CASE TO BE MADE HERE BUT
I DO THINK IT'S WORTH. FLESHING
OUT THESE DETAILS AND I
ANTICIPATE ONCE WE DO SO THAT
WILL FIND THAT THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT THERE'S-
INVISIBLE. AND UNDETECTED
PROBLEMS OCCURRING ALL OVER THE
PLACE THAT THE AIR DISTRICTS ARE
SIMPLY UNABLE TO COVER SO WITH
THAT I YIELD MY TIME. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN SO I'VE SAT ON THIS
COMMITTEE NOW AND IT IS MY THIRD
YEAR AND- WE HAVE INCREASED THE
AMOUNT OF- PERSONNEL FOR
CALOGERO AND WE HAVE. AGENCY
WATCHING AGENCIES WATCHING
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA ALL WE DO
IS TAKE TAKE THE CONTROL AWAY
FROM THE LOCAL. AIR DISTRICT OR
THE LOCAL PERMITTING AGENCY AND
WE'VE CREATED QUITE FRANKLY YOU
KNOW. MORE GOVERNMENT-
BUREAUCRATS WATCHING IN IN NOT
GETTING THE JOB DONE SO I ONE
EIGHT I WANT YOU TO EXPLAIN TO
ME. IF THESE POSITIONS WERE
FILLED. ENGHIEN GIVE THIS THIS
COMMITTEE SOME CONFIDENCE THAT
SOMETHING'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAPPEN WE HAVE A THOUSAND. WELLS
THE OIL WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
WAITING TO BE PERMITTED AT
KALYAN AND WE'VE INCREASED THE
F. T. E.'S AT CAL JIM. EVERY
YEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE BY.
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY POSITIONS
BUT WE CAN'T SEEM TO GET THE JOB
DONE SO CAN YOU CAN YOU TELL ME
WHY I SHOULD SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST- AND GIVE US THIS
COMMITTEE SOME CONFIDENCE IN HOW
THE HOW IT'S GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTED ANDWHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA DO. TO SAVE THE
ENVIRONMENT. RIGHT SO WITH
REGARD TO THE AIR QUALITY
REGULATIONS THAT THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS- EMPLOYMENT AND THAT
CARP IMPLEMENTS- THERE ARE. WITH
THESE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WILL
DO- IS PROVIDE- RESOURCES TO
DIRECTLY ENFORCE CARBS OWN
METHANE REGULATIONS- PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO THE DISTRICTS- IN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF IMITATION OF
THEIR ROLES AND DOING THAT
THROUGH OUR- STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITY TO. PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT- WE HAVE ONE OF PERSON
AT CARB BUT ABLE TO DO THIS TYPE
OF WORK IT'S NOT BEEN ENOUGH-
WE'RE GETTING- CONTINUED
COMPLAINTS ABOUT ISSUES COMING
FROM THESE FACILITIES- AND SO
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
WAY FOR US TO- TO SORT OF BUILD
UP NOT CAPACITY TO CONTINUE THIS
WORK- AGAIN DIRECTLY ENFORCING
OUR PROGRAMS. SUPPORTING THE
DISTRICTS AND PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT DO DO THE DISTRICTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE THE
METHANE RULE. SOME DO THROUGH-
DELEGATED AUTHORITY FOR ANIMAL
USE THAT WE'VE ENTERED INTO I'M
NOT ALL DISTRICTS HAVE ENTERED
INTO EMILY IS WITH US- AND SO IN
THOSE. PARTICULAR AREAS THE CARD
IS- THE ONLY RESOURCE OUT THERE
ENFORCING- THE METHANE RULES AND
THEN WITH THE OTHER DISTRICTS
THEY ARE OUT THERE WE ALL TO GO
OUT THERE WITH THEM PERIODICALLY
HOW MANY HOW MANY DISTRICTS
HAVE- USE SIGNED A- MOU WITH AND
HOW MANY HAVE NOT. SO THERE ARE
A TOTAL OF THIRTY FIVE AIR
DISTRICTS- I CAN GO BACK AND GET
THAT NUMBER HAVE HAVE EMPLOYEES
BUT THAT'S IT THE PRIMARY ONES
DO- MORE OF THE WORLD DISTRICTS
MAYBE DO NOT- BUT I CAN COME
BACK WITH MORE. SO WHAT I'M
HEARING IS THAT THE ONES WHO
PROBABLY HAVE A METHANE.
PROBLEMS ARE SIGNED UP WITH. I
HAVE AN MO YOU IF YOU. SEVERAL
OF THEM DO YEAH. SO THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY THEN TO ENFORCE THE
METHANE RULE. THEY DO. AND HOW
MANY OF THOSE- OUR FUNDED. D.
DOES THIS CAR ACTUALLY GIVE THEM
FUNDING OR IS THAT FUNDING COME
FROM THE LOCAL- MISSPELLED HIS
OR OR GOVERNMENTS. LEAVE WITH
PER PROVIDE FUNDING THROUGH THE
AMMONIA. SO IF THEY IF THEY HAVE
A MORE YOU WITH YOU AND YET AND
THE PROVIDE FUNDING FORM WHY
WOULD WE NEED THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE WE ARE STILL RECEIVING
COMPLAINTS THAT THERE ARE STILL
ISSUES AT THESE FACILITIES- WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THOSE
ISSUES ARE FOUND TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS- TO ADDRESS THOSE. THOSE
CONCERNS- THE COMPLAINTS THAT
WERE RECEIVING HAVE TO DEAL WITH
EXCESS EMISSIONS- HEALTH IMPACTS
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING VOTERS YOU KNOW
THINGS OF THAT NATURE- SO AGAIN
THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP US
FULFILL OUR ROLE- ENSURING THAT-
THAT. OUR RULE IS BEING ENFORCED
AS IT SHOULD WE HAVE EVER USED
BUT WE RETAIN. YOU KNOW WE DON'T
GIVE UP OUR RIGHT TO ENFORCE- WE
RETAIN ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY OF
OUR OWN PROGRAM EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE AND WERE USED- AND
THEN ALSO TO FULFILL OUR
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT. TO ENSURE
THAT YOU KNOW EVERYTHING IS
BEING ENFORCED CONSISTENTLY.
ENFORCED AS IT NEEDS TO BE- YOU
KNOW COORDINATING EFFORTS
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO EACH OTHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE ISSUES
AND CONCERNS ARE RESOLVED. A YOU
TELL ME WHAT PART OF THE STATE
ARE YOU GETTING MOST THESE
COMPLAINTS FROM. I CANNOT SAY AT
THE MOMENT THEY'RE THEY'RE
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU. OKAY I'M-
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER HAVE A
HANDS UP WHEN YOU GIVE OUR
RESPONSE TO THE PROGRAM CAN YOU
INCLUDE HOW MANY STAFF DO YOU
HAVE A SIGN TO DO- THE AB SIX
ONE SEVEN PROGRAM AND
ENFORCEMENT AND A LITTLE LITTLE
FURTHER EXPLANATION ON WHY THEY
CAN'T BE USED FOR THE FOR THIS
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION THAT HAPPENS
WITH CARBON BE GREAT AND WITH
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO. HOLD THIS
MATTER AND MOVE ON THANK AT THE
AIRPORT- FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND MOVE ON TO. ISSUE NUMBER
NINE WHICH IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES AND RECOVERY ALSO
KNOWN AS CAL RECYCLE IN THIS IS
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
- STRENGTHENING THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY WITH CONSUMER RECYCLING
CREDITS AND MARKET IN
INCENTIVES- WE HAVE- TREKKER
WAGNER AND HER STAFF THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- THIS WAGNER YOU HAVE
A PRESENTATION. ON THIS PC PCP.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GATE AND MEMBERS AT THE PLEASURE
TO BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY AS I
AS YOU STATED- I HAD I AM JOINED
TODAY BY MY CHIEF DEPUTY AT MANY
MCINTYRE AND I'LL JUST SLIGHTLY
OFF SCREEN AT AT W. DIRECTOR AMY
CAMERON WHO OVERSEES AND THE
NEED BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM WE ARE VERY
PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU AT TODAY
TO PRESENT OUR SPRING FINANCE
LETTER PROPOSAL FROM ON BEHALF
OF THE ADMINISTRATION TO EXPENSE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM. TO
FACILITATE FAR GREATER ACCESS TO
THIS PROGRAM AND TO PUT AT
DOLLARS BACK IN CONSUMERS HANDS
- CREDIT THEM FOR THE AT C. R.
V. THAT THEY HAD THEMSELVES PAID
ON THE BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THEY
PURCHASED AS YOU KNOW OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC CONSUMER
HABITS HAVE CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY ALLEN BEVERAGE
CONTAINER PURCHASE CHAIN HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY AS NOTED
AND THE COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. THAT
INCREASED AND- CONTAINER
PURCHASING HAS RESULTED IN AN
INFLUX OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM AND
FIND AND WE THINK THAT THE BEST
WAY FOR US TO UTILIZE THAT
FUNDING AT THIS JUNCTURE IS TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT REALLY VERY
QUICKLY IMPLEMENT SOME SOLUTIONS
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO OUR
RECYCLING DESERT AND TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY CONSUMER HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE THEIR C.
R. V. BACK. I'M GOING THROUGH
THE PROPOSAL AND WE HAD FIRST
AND FOREMOST AND A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS FOR
THE- FOR- DEPLOYMENT I.
RIVERSIDE AND MACHINES ROUGHLY
TWO THOUSAND VENDING ACROSS THE
STATE AT. SUCH AS UNIVERSITIES-
OR HIGH SCHOOLS AND TO YOU OUR
PARTNERS- IN THE RETAIL.
INDUSTRY ARE GROCERS TO TRULY
PROVIDE REATER ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND IN A WAY THAT- CREATES A FAR
GREATER ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM
FOR OUR CONSUMERS- ADDITIONALLY
WE HAVE SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR MOBILE RECYCLING THAT WOULD
HAVE. ALLOWED IT THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONTRACT- WITH AND EITHER THE
CONSERVATION CORPS IS THE LOCAL
COURSE THE STATE COURT- OR
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS TO DEPLOY A
SOME FORM OF MOBILE RECYCLING
THAT COULD VERY QUICKLY BE
DISPATCHED TO AGAIN OUR
RECYCLING DESERT IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR THOSE REGIONS.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE AS YOU KNOW
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
RECYCLING CREDIT AND THIS PART
OF THE PROPOSAL WAS REALLY AIMED
AT AT RETURNING THESE- DOLLARS
AND SENSE BACK TO CONSUMERS- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS MONEY BELONGS
TO THEM THIS IS THEIR MONEY AND
WE LIKE TO DO. TO GET IT BACK TO
CONSUMERS AND WE THINK THAT
PROVIDING THIS CONSUMER CREDIT
IS AN INCENTIVE TO GO INTO THE
INTO YOU AT THE TREASURE TROVES
OF RECYCLING AND MATERIALS THAT
AND BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE IN THEIR GARAGES AND
BRING THOSE OUT. AND GET THEM
RECYCLED SO CREATING A SHORT
TERM PROGRAM BY WHICH WOULD
HOPEFULLY BE AN INCENTIVE FOR
CONSUMERS TO BRING BACK- THE
BOTTLES AND CANS THAT THEY HAVE
IN THEIR GARAGES AND THEN WE.
HAV ANOTHER- TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NEW INVEST.
TECHNOLOGY AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- AND WITH THAT
SENATOR AND I HAD TURNED IT BACK
TO YOU. THANK YOU MISTER BROWN
WITH THE L. A- DO YOU HAVE AN
OPINION ON THE P. C. P. PROPOSAL
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION. HELLO
AGAIN AS CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LA- WE DO HAVE
SOME COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL-
SO WE DO THINK GIVEN RECENT
DECLINES AND RECYCLING RATES AND
CONSUMER ACCESS. TO RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES AND A SUBSTANTIAL
FINE BALANCE IN THE FUND WE
THINK PROVIDING SOMEONE TIME
FUNDING TO TRY TO IMPROVE
PROGRAM OUTCOMES COULD HAVE A
LOT OF MERIT. HOWEVER WE THINK
THE SPECIFIC PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS HERE LACKS SOME KEY
DETAILS AND RAISES SOME
IMPORTANT POLICY QUESTIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. AND
SIMILAR TO LAST ITEM ASTON
MINISTRATION TO ADDRESS
IMMIGRANTS DAYS SO NO RUN
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE- KEY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE FOUR OF THEM.
SO FIRST DOES THE PROPOSAL
ADDRESS A ORDERS OF THE SPECIFIC
PIECE OF THE PROPOSAL ADDRESS A
WELL IDENTIFIED PROBLEM SO
CERTAIN PIECES SUCH AS THE
AUTOMATIC RECYCLING MACHINES
WE'VE BEEN CONTENT TO ADDRESS A
VERY WELL KNOWN PROBLEM OF
CONSUMER ACCESS TO. RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES HOWEVER IN OTHER
CASES. WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEM OR
EXACTLY HOW THE PROPOSAL WOULD
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM SO. FOR
EXAMPLE- ACCORDING TO
ADMINISTRATION THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT FOR THE TEMPORARY
INCREASE IN C. R. V. VALUE- IS
MEANT TO ADDRESS THE KIND OF
LARGE NUMBER OF CONTAINERS THAT
CONSUMERS PURCHASED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THAT ARE. ACTUALLY
STORING. HOWEVER WE HAVEN'T YET
SEEN MUCH KIND OF CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT CONSUMERS ARE
STORING LARGE AMOUNTS OF
CONTAINERS THAT THEY PURCHASED
DURING THE PANDEMIC. BUT EVEN IF
THEY ARE IT'S UNCLEAR HOW A
TEMPORARY INCREASE IN THE
BENEFIT ODING HER INTRODUCTION
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE OTHERWISE
HEARD SO PRESUMABLY. CONSUMERS
RESTORING BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
WITH SOME INTENSE READING THEM
IN THE FUTURE AND A TEMPORARY
INCREASE IN THE C. R. V.
ASSEMBLY SHIFT THE DATE BUT THE
CONCEPT IN GENERAL ARE GAMES BUT
HAVE VERY LITTLE IMPACT ON THE
OVERALL NUMBERS OF CONTAINERS.
THAT ARE EVENTUALLY RECYCLES. SO
SECOND. QUESTION WE THINK HOW IF
IS EACH PIECE OF THE PROPOSED
ADDRESS- THEY PROBLEM IS BUT I-
THE MINISTRY HASN'T PROVIDED.
AND ABOUT THE DEGREE TO WHICH
PROPOSED SIX. TO THE RECYCLING
GOALS INCREASE IN RECYCLING RATE
SOARING. IN AND THE LEGISLATURE
WONDER UNITS. TO REPORT ON THE
REGIONAL. EACH PROGRAM TO
EXPECTED TO ACHIEVE SOME OF
THESE DIFFERENT GOAL. THIRD THIS
RELATES TO THE- PREVIOUS POINT
HOWEVER THERE IS A FROM THE-
PILOT PROGRAMS AND FORM THIS
PROPOSAL SAID THE COMMITTEE I'M
IS AWARE OF HOW RECYCLE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING. FIVE PILOTS AIMED
AT EXPLORING ALTERNATIVE
PRODUCTION OPTIONS- AND IS
PLANNING TO EXPAND BASED ON-
BUDGET ACTIONS TAKEN LAST YEAR
TO AN ADDITIONAL FIVE PILOTS-
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
CONDUCTED AN EVALUATION OF THESE
PILOTS YEAH AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANNA DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT ON THE
PROGRESS OF THOSE PILOTS. WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE PRIMARY OUTCOMES
G. LESSONS LEARNED. AND HOW
THOSE PILOTS HAVE INFORMED US-
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL ENOUGH
IF NO RESULTS ARE AVAILABLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER. THE
WAY. FUNDING AND SO MORE. IT'S
AVAILABLE. AND THEN THE FINAL
ISSUE OF IS DOES THE HAS ON TO
HAVE SO THE LEGISLATURE MY WANT
TO CAN WAYS TO TARGET FUNDING
ACTIVE THERE ARE WE DON'T ON THE
REST LIKE RATES AND RATHER THAN
THIS ONE TIME BUT- WE THINK THAT
SOME OF THE IN PROPOSAL HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO INCREASE RECYCLING
ON AN ONGOING BASIS SUCH AS THE
AUTOMATIC RECYCLING MACHINES IN
SUPERMARKETS- PROVIDING LOANS TO
RECYCLERS I CAN BE FORGIVEN IF
THE RECYCLER OPERATES FOR A
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF TIME. IN OTHER
CASES SUCH AS THAT THE INCREASED
TEMPORARY C. R. B. VALUE THE
PROPOSAL WOULD LIKELY YIELD ONLY
A LIMITED TERM RESULTS AND SO
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO-
DIRECT ADMINISTRATION REPORT ON
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE MOST LIKELY
TO HAVE THOSE LONG TERM
RECYCLING BENEFITS AND PERHAPS
FOCUS FUNDING PRIMARILY ON THOSE
TYPES OF EFFORTS SO THAT SO
THAT- IN MY COMMENTS THERE AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD I'M SUPPOSED TO
OCCASIONALLY ANNOUNCED THAT THE
PUBLIC CALL IN NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS FOURTEEN ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO- FINANCE YOU HAVE ANYTHING
TO ADD- GIVEN. MR BROWN'S
COMMENTS. YEAH THANK YOU CHAIR
BECAUSE HE A MEMBER THIS IS BALE
WITH THE- OF- I DO LIKE TO ASK
THAT THE IN. HAS REVIEWED AND
ANALYZED THE SIXTY BALANCE. AND
HAS INCLUDED A THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
CRIMINOLOGY SHE OF RESOURCES
FROM THE EXISTING BALANCE BCRF.
THE CURRENT ESTIMATED FUND
BALANCE FOR BCRF IS
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IF
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES THIS
PROPOSAL THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THAT VCR UP WILL
MAINTAIN A PRUDENT LEVEL OF
PROJECTED FUND BALANCE FOR THE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE BUDGET
YEAR. APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS OTHER THAN
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF NUMBERS. YEAH
MISTER L. TWENTY CENTER STAGE DE
THAT. WHAT THE MAXIMUM CAN BE IN
THIS FUND BALANCE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT OVER THERE IN FINANCE. I AM
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION FOURTEEN. FIVE EIGHT
ZERO I BELIEVE OF ANY RENT TO
SEIZE A PARENTHESES TO PROTECT.
YES AND I THINK I'LL FOR
RESEARCH- FOR K. WHICH SHALL NOT
BE GREATER WELL THAT'S
INTERESTING SHALL NOT BE GREATER
THAN AN AMOUNT EQUAL TO FIVE
PERCENT. OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT
PAID TO PROCESSORS DURING THE
PRECEDING CALENDAR YEAR SO WE
GOT SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION AND YOU'RE AT THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY WALK US THROUGH
THE MATH OF WHAT. HOW YOU'RE
MAKING YOUR CALCULATIONS. HAPPY
THE IT PROVIDES AN INSIGHT THERE
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ALSO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO YOUR STAFF AT A
LATER POINT SO- FIRST AND
FOREMOST BE LANGUAGE THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO. THE 5% FOR THE
RESERVE IS DIFFERENT FROM-
LEGALLY DEFINED FOR AN EXISTING
FUND BALANCE SO A RESERVE IS
BASICALLY DEFINED AS A
CONTINGENCY RESERVE THAT IS
UTILIZED IN STEARNS
CIRCUMSTANCES PARTICULARLY FOR
WHEN THERE'S ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS.
AND IT IS. ACTUALLY ASIDE FOR
THAT PURPOSE. THE EXISTING FUND
BALANCE IS AN ACCUMULATION OF
SIGNIFICANT REVENUES THAT
ACCUMULATED OVER TIME COMPARED
TO THE AMOUNT OF EXPENDITURES
THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED. FOR
THOSE YEARS AND SO FOR THAT
PURPOSE THAT DIFFERENCE IN THAT
LANGUAGE DOES NOT NECESSARILY
APPLY IN. THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION. WELL A FEW MONTHS AGO
- CAL RECYCLE WAS BEFORE US AND
THEY SAID THE RESERVE AT THAT
TIME WAS FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION- AND- NOW THE
DEPARTMENT REPORTS THAT THE FUND
BALANCE IS THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION WHICH IS AND-
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED MILLION MORE.
BUT YOUR CALCULATION YOUR BCP
HASN'T CHANGED. AT LEAST AT
LEAST WE GOT THAT NUMBER
WOULDN'T SHOULD THERE BE AN
ADJUSTMENT. EVEN GIVEN YOUR
LIMITED INTERPRETATION OF THE 5%
CONTINGENCY FUND. SO I PROBABLY
WOULD JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT
AGAIN THERE'S JUST THE NEW ONES
THERE- IN TERMS OF A RESERVE AND
A FINE BALANCE THE EASY P. DOES
HAVE IT UPDATED AND MOST RECENT
UPDATED BY THE VISION STATEMENT.
WHICH IS- THE MOST RECENT ACTUAL
NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR- AS WELL AS THE
PROJECTED FUND BALANCE FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR SO AS YOU NOTED THE
NUMBERS IN THE B. C. P. ARE THE
MOST RECENT NUMBERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS. AT THIS
POINT IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
MOST OF US HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE LOOK AT A MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THE MAXIMUM REQUIREMENT THERE'S
THIS IS AN ODD THING THAT YOU
SAY THE MAXIMUM RESERVE SHALL BE
YOU KNOW. 5% AND EVEN THEN YEAR
EVEN IN YOUR CALCULATION IT WITH
THE CONTINGENCY THE RESERVE
LIMIT. DOESN'T THAT REQUIRE A
DIFFERENT CALCULATION BY
FINANCING BY THE CAL RECYCLE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE
I HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU I
AND I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS AND HOW WE GENERALLY
LOOK MOST OF THE TIME AT
MINIMUM- VERSES MAXIMUM- BUT I
WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO FOLLOW
UP WELL LET ME PUT A DIFFERENT
WAY WHAT'S A HEALTHY RESERVE
RIGHT WHAT THE HELL TO RESERVE
WE HAVE YOU KNOW. THE- P. R. C.
ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT ZERO PRINT
TO SEIZE A PRINCESS TO THE TALK
ABOUT. CONTINGENCY WHAT DO YOU
WHAT THIS FINANCE WHAT THIS IS
SAID MINISTRATION THINK AS I
HELP THE RESERVE- FOR PEOPLE'S
DEPOSITS. THAT ARE BEING HELD.
DO WE HAVE A NUMBER THERE. WHEN
IT IS TIME FOR A MINIMUM
RESEARCH FOR THIS ARTICLE I MEAN
LOOKING AT IT DIFFERENTLY. IT
OKAY- YEAH YES THEIR DRIVER PART
OF FINE AND- DID YOU HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT HERE TO- SO.
GENERALLY WORK FOR MANY
DIFFERENT TACK TO FIND YOU KNOW
WE THINK ABOUT LIKE- 5210% KIND
OF YOU KNOW GOOD RESERVE
RESERVE. HOWEVER IN CERTAIN
CASES. WHERE THERE'S POTENTIAL
VOLATILITY WITH EITHER THE LEVEL
OF RAM YOU ALREADY PATRICK I'M
TRYING TO TAKE A LOT MORE
PRUDENT TO HAVE A HIGHER LEVEL
OVER THERE. IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN
THERE'S I THINK YOU HAVE
UNDERLYING FACTORS WHY WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS. A KIND OF
MORE PRUDENT LEVEL TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF A I RESERVE I
THINK ONE IS. WHEN WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE REVENUES OVER
THE COURSE OF ENDEMIC WE THOUGHT
YOUR CONSUMER BEHAVIOR
TECHNICALLY CHANGED TO WHAT IT
WAS BEFORE. NOW THAT THE CURRENT
CONDITION THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT DOES
THE FILM- CHARACTER AND LEVEL OF
CONTINUED OUR BEHAVIOR LOOK AT
THAT REVENUE FROM. THEIR
PROJECTED CURRENT YEAR AND
BUDGET YEAR THEY'D MAKE A PRETTY
FLAT WHICH MEANS THAT WE ARE
MOVING IN THE BUDGET YEAR WHAT
THE SIMILAR TYPE BEHAVIOR.
HOWEVER THERE STILL EMERGENCY
AFTER AFTER WHETHER THAT WILL
ACTUALLY CONTINUE AT THIS POINT
BASED OFF OF THE DAY THAT WE
HAVE- WE THINK IT COULD. BUT NOW
EVERYTHING'S OPENING BACK UP AND
BE OF PEOPLE MAY NOT BE BUYING
IT MAY BORROW GOOD THAT COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY SHAPE. SHIFT WHAT
IT WHAT AT THAT AMPLE THAT AND
THAT UNCERTAINTY OF. ALL REVENUE
COULD CALL THE RELIEF IMPACT
REFUND ABOUT AND THE THANK THE A
THIS PROPOSAL- KNOW ONE OF THE
BIG COMPONENT THAT THE INCREASE
THE REDUCTION OPPORTUNITY. TO
THEN BE ABLE TO CREATE ACCESS
AND THEN ULTIMATELY BE ABLE TO
INCREASE OUR RECYCLING RATE
WHICH INCREASED IN THE REFINERY
IS IT'S GOOD BECAUSE WE WANT TO
GET TO. B. B. AND YOU KNOW HE
THANK ALL HOWEVER WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IF AND I NEED AT THE FUND
BALANCE. AND FLOW WOULD BE
THINKING ONE TIME AND- ARE KNOW
HOPEFULLY WHICH IS OUR GOAL
CONNECTING- THE LEVEL OF YOU
KNOW. REPEAT THE RV THAT WE GET
OUT. WHICH IS GOING EIGHT THE
FUND BALANCE IN MOST LIKELY A
KIND OF THE OUT YOUR- AND WE'RE
NOT BE TWO P. THAT. ARE SOMEWHAT
FOLLOWED TILED- THE FUND BALANCE
ARE BEING X. PRUDENT THAT
LEAVING A HIGH LEVEL THIRD.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IF WE DON'T AND
THE YOU'RE EITHER REVENUE IF WE
AGAIN. OR BE INCREASE OUR OUT-
RETENTION RATE INCREASE AGAIN.
THEN KNOW WE MAY GET A NEW AREA
WHERE. WE'RE IT OR A REDUCTION.
AND LOW. FOR THOSE WHO READ AND
WE CAN GET CASE IT IS MORE TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT LEVEL RATHER.
LAND AND THE WITH KIND OF YOU
KNOW ALL BUDGET- IS NOT EVERY IS
SAYING. DONE WITH SOMEONE MISHAP
FIVE I'VE NEVER MAKE MAKE THEN
IN THIS CASE. IN MAKES SENSE
THAT GIVER A LITTLE BIT MORE A
BOOK. YEAH MISTER. THE WHY.
WHAT'S A HEALTHY. IS HE NOW AND
I WAS A LIE OF INFORMATION
THERE- WE NOTE THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN A FUN BALANCE WE'VE GOT
BACK AND FORTH I'VE BEEN FOR
FIVE YEARS MANY OF MY- TO BE.
HERE FOR FIVE YEARS IN THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT WHAT THE REPORT
FROM BALANCES GOING TO BE MAY
AND WHAT IT IS IN OCTOBER AND WE
GO BACK IN. FORTH BOOK WELL I
HAVE I KNOW MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT THEY WANT TO ASK
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO. TO THEM
MISS. WEGNER DIRECT WAGNER WERE
YOUR STAFF ON THE- ROAD YOU HAVE
A COMMENT OR A AND AN- ON THE-
I'M I'M EQUAL 25% OF THE TOTAL
AMOUNT PAID TO PROCESSOR. 10% DO
YOU HAVE WELL I YOU KNOW BECAUSE
OLD HABITS DIE HARD SENATOR AND
AT YOU KNOW AND READING OF THE
LANGUAGE OF THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT I THINK THAT THAT
FIVE PERCENT. THE RESERVE FOR
CONTINGENCIES WHICH SHALL NOT BE
GREATER THAN AN AMOUNT EQUAL 25%
OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT PAID TO
PROCESSORS AND THE FACT THAT IT
WAS NOT GREATER THAN IS
REFERRING BACK TO THAT SAID A
LANGUAGE RELATING TO YOU
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED SO I
THINK WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CRAFTED THIS LANGUAGE IT WAS
INTENDED TO PREVENT THE AD
DEPARTMENT. FROM BUT. I'M FROM
AND- WHAT MAKES- HOLDING MORE
THAN THE 5% SO I THINK IT'S FOR
THE PURPOSE OF A DIRECT
APPROPRIATION SO IT IS
MAINTAINING THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROPRIATION CONTROL WHICH IS-
SUB FEET THAT THE REST OF THE
MONEY IN THE FIND AND ABOVE AND
BEYOND THAT- RESERVE FOR
CONTINGENCIES IS THAT
LEGISLATORS TO APPROPRIATE NOT
THE DEPARTMENTS TO- CONTINUE
WITH. RESPECT MISTER BROWN DO
YOU READ THAT. SECTION OF THE
CODE THAT WAY. I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE HAVE KIND OF A- SPECIAL KIND
OF POSITION ON THE READING OF
THE CODE BUT I DO THINK THE- THE
POINT THE DIRECTOR WAGNER IS
MAKING WE THINK IT'S KIND OF AN
IMPORTANT ONE FOR THE
LEGISLATION THE COMMITTEE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT WHICH IS-
ULTIMATELY WE THINK KIND OF THE
OF THE LEGISLATURE OR SORT OF
HAS CONTROL OVER KIND OF THIS.
SPENDING AUTHORITY SORT OF EVEN
WHAT THIS- KIND OF PIECE OF
LANGUAGE IN PLACE. IT IS
STATUTORY THAT CAN SORT OF
CHANGE THAT- CHANGE CHANGE THAT
LANGUAGE IF IT WANTED TO- BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY I WOULD THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO SORT
OF. ALLOCATE THE MONEY THAT IS
IN THE FUNDS. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
KIND OF REQUIRE. LEGISLATIVE
SPENDING AUTHORITY. TO DO THAT
SO THE DECISIONS AROUND. HOW
MUCH MONEY TO ALLOCATE AND WORD
OF SORT OF ALLOCATE THE FUNDS
ULTIMATELY WE THINK ARE KIND OF.
THE LEGISLATURE. IN KIND OF
GOING FOR DESIGNING SORT OF HOW
BIG OF A FINE BALANCE OF WANTS
TO KEEP AND WHERE IT WANTS TO-
TO. ALLOCATE SOME MONEY TO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE ITS GOALS. YOU CAN YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND MY CONFUSION
SINCE THIS SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
SENATE PROPOSED. BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE LAST YEAR TO EXPAND TO
SOME MONEY INTO AREAS THAT WERE
DESERT'S AND THAT WOULD WITH
THAT. FINANCE AND CAL RECYCLE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WAS
UNABLE TO GET THERE ON AN
AGREEMENT- MR. A. CENTER DOLLY
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS. YOU'RE
FINE SENATOR MCGUIRE DO YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS. SEVERAL PARTY
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN DO APPRECIATE
REPRESENTATIVES WHO ARE ON THE
LINE I THROUGH THE CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO START WITH
SOME QUESTIONS- TO THE DIRECTOR-
MADAM DIRECTOR- WE'VE HAD
OPPORTUNITIES ALONG WITH A CHAIR
AND I TO BE IN A TALK ABOUT
RECYCLING IN RURAL CALIFORNIA-
YOU ARE MAKING. PROGRESS ON
THESE RECYCLING CENTERS FOR
EXAMPLE IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY- RE
OPENING. A RECYCLING CENTER. TO
THE PUBLIC CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT YOUR PROGRESS. ON YOUR
SCREEN IN REGARDS TO RURAL
CALIFORNIA THESE RECYCLING
CENTERS IN THE IN OUT WHAT ARE
THE NEXT STEPS PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE QUESTION ALLEN I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT AGAIN APPLIED AT THE
CITY OF ARCADE AT THE COUNTY OF
HUMBOLDT AND OUR PARTNERS AT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION WE'RE REALLY
WORKING THROUGH THE PROCESS I
KNOW THE RECYCLING CENTER THERE
AND ARCADA. AND AT HAS BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD OVER THE
BALLOT THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TO GET RE OPENED AND THEY JUST
RE OPENED A COUPLE WEEKS AGO TO-
RECORD LINES OF PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO REDEEM THEIR BOTTLES AND CANS
AND SO IT REALLY JUST SHOWS THAT
WHEN WE PROVIDE ACCESS. TO THIS
PROGRAM THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY
INTERESTS AND ARE THE RURAL
PARTS OF OUR STATE AND SO I JUST
REALLY AGAIN WANT TO APPLAUD
THOSE WHO WERE A PART OF THAT
PROCESS AND THAT REALLY
HIGHLIGHT THAT YOU KNOW THAT IT
WAS A CHALLENGE IT TOOK ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FOR THAT CENTER
TO GET OPENED AND WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE- AB. I A
QUICKER TURNAROUND ON GETTING
RECYCLING CENTERS OPEN AND
PROVIDING GREATER LEVELS OF
ACCESS AND IN FOR PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE I WOULD NEED A NEW
RECYCLING CENTER MAY NOT. BE
ABLE TO OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES
HOW CAN WE FACILITATE AND AS YOU
GUYS KNOW HE- PILOT PROJECTS
WERE VERY MUCH INTENDED TO DO
JUST THAT PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM AND
PROVIDE THAT SERVICE. TO THEIR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS- WE HAVE
FIVE PILOT PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY RUNNING THEY WERE VERY
SLOW ON GETTING STARTED BY NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN UNFORTUNATELY
WE PASSED THAT STATUTE WE PASSED
THE APPROPRIATION TO HELP THEM
GET STARTED. AND THEN THEY WERE
HIT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS
LONG WITH THE REST OF THE PLANET
EACH OF US INDIVIDUALLY WERE HIT
WITH A PANDEMIC THAT IMPEDED THE
ABILITY TO GET THOSE PILOT
PROJECTS STARTED BUT THEY ARE
NOW AS OF. TODAY ALL UP AND
RUNNING AND TESTING SOME REALLY
INTERESTING IDEAS AROUND. SOME
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE CAN
INTEGRATE INTO TO THE STATE. I
FORGET REGION AND TIME. OF
PEOPLE AND GEOGRAPHIC'S I HAD TO
REALLY THAT PROVIDE A GREATER
LEVEL OF SERVICE ACROSS THE
STATE SO- AS YOU KNOW SENATOR AS
YOU KNOW COUNTY HAS DONE A
REALLY INTERESTING PILOT PROJECT
WHERE THEY'RE WORKING WITH I
THINK IS THAT FIVE OR SIX
DIFFERENT THIRDS DICTION. WITH
IN ALBANY DID YOU TAKE BACK- AND
IT TOOK A WHILE TO GET THAT
STARTED THAT WAS A LOT TO
ORGANIZE BUT THEY ARE NOW UP AND
RUNNING AND WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED AND OF AND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A COUPLE YEARS. BUT WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE
OUTCOME OF THAT TYPE OF SYSTEM-
THE PILOT PROJECT IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE ONE AND IRVINE TO
CULVER CITY. SAN MATTEO THEY'RE
ALSO TETING SOME NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND NEW TYPES OF
SYSTEMS AND FLEXIBILITIES IN THE
SYSTEM SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY-
PROPOSING IN THIS PROPOSAL. IS
TO BUILD OFF OF SOME OF THAT.
AND WHAT WORKS ADDITIONALLY
SEEING. IN THE PILOT PROJECTS-
AND USING SOME OF THE STATE
REYES AND DEPLOYING THEM AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO SOME OF THESE
OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO DO IT
THEMSELVES WERE ALSO VERY
EXCITED TO SEE I THINK WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS. OUT WITH TEN ADDITIONAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE. LOOKING
TO APPLY THE PILOT PROGRAM SO
THERE'S A LOT HAPPENING IT'S
JUST VERY EARLY DAYS. SO THEY
JUST WANT TO GO INTO THAT AND
THROUGH THE CHAIR AND I WANT TO
JUST TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
SCRAP I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE SEEING-
THROUGHOUT BUT- SAID. ONE OF THE
SUGGEST BEING CANDID I THINK ONE
OF THE WHY WE'RE SEEING SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT SURPLUS. IS THE LACK
OF ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
BE ABLE TO. TURN IN THEIR
RESPECT RECYCLED MATERIAL. SO WE
HAVE THESE KIND OF PROJECTS-
MADAM DIRECTOR IF YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT. HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RE OPEN ON A MORE
AGGRESSIVE BASIS. AND I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU COVERED HAS
WREAKED HAVOC ON SO MANY AREAS
INCLUDING. GETTING NEEDS RURAL
CENTER IS BACK OPEN. BUT I THINK
WHAT YOU SAID VERY ELOQUENTLY TO
ME HE IS AT TWENTY OR PRIORITIES
IS LOOKING AT. RE OPENING
RECYCLING CENTERS AND
INCENTIVIZING CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT GIVE US
YOUR IDEAS ON THAT- IN IN IN
PARTICULAR FOR RURAL CALIFORNIA.
YOU REALLY HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE
RIGHT YOU'RE EITHER THROWING A
LANDFILL OR YOU'RE TAKING TO
RECYCLING CENTER AND THERE'S NO
IN BETWEEN. SO IF YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT A BROADER ABOVE AND BEYOND
THESE. KIND OF PROJECTS IN YOUR
THOUGHTS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO THAT'S -
RIGHT AND AS YOU AND I ARE BOTH
FROM A RURAL PART OF THE STATE
AND AT PROBABLY IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF OUR LIVES. HAD PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS AND SO I AM
VERY VERY PERSONALLY. AS
SENSITIVE AND AWARE TO THE
CHALLENGES OF RURAL CALIFORNIA
BUT IT ALSO EXTENDS TO URBAN
PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE. PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS. TO TO
RECYCLING CENTERS- WHERE AT THE
PRICE OF REAL ESTATE IS REALLY
HÌNH SAID THE CHALLENGES ARE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT. LOCATIONS UT GETTING
A PERMANENT SOLUTION- FOR THOSE
REGIONS THAT MAY NOT BRING IN.
THE NUMBER OF BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS TO REALLY MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STATUTE AND
- BE A FREE STANDING- MONEY
MAKING BUSINESS. IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE AND I THINK. HE'S BEEN
PART OF WHAT WE SEE. IN RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE IS THEY'RE
NOT BRINGING IN ENOUGH BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. TO MAKE THE BUSINESS
MAKE SENSE AND I THINK. AS YOU
KNOW TRANSPORTATION COSTS TO
PROCESSING CENTERS THE COST OF
REAL ESTATE ACOSTA PERMITTING
THE COST OF. AS HAVING AND-
EMPLOYEES THERE. THE FOR HOURS
WHERE THEY'RE NOT BRINGING IN
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS ARE ALL
THINGS. THAT IF WE COULD IMPART
SOME FLEXIBILITY INTO THE
SYSTEM. WOULD AG. BE MAKE IT
MORE LIKELY THAT THESE-
RECYCLING CENTERS COULD SIXTEEN
IN PLACES LIKE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
LIKE MENDOCINO COUNTY- YOU
COUNTY. ALPINE COUNTY SOME OF
THE COUNTIES THAT WE KNOW ARE
CONSTANTLY STRUGGLING- AND AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN LAST YEAR WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE COMPONENTS OF
AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN SEVERAL OF
WHICH WILL REQUIRE US TO DOT.
REGULATIONS BUT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO FAST TRACK THOSE
REGULATIONS BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
THE FLEXIBILITY AND- HOURS. OF
OPERATION- AT THE FLOOD. AND
HAVE AND- TO BRING AND BACKDROP
SO. IMPARTING SOME OF THIS
FLEXIBILITY TO RECYCLING CENTERS
I IN PARTS OF OUR STATE THAT ARE
NOT GOING TO SEE THE CONSISTENCY
OF HIGH VOLUME WILL HOPEFULLY
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A BUSINESS
MODEL THAT MAKES SENSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND I
THINK THAT- IN. AS YOU'RE
DISCUSSING- CENTER DOLLY I JUST
MADE A COMMENT AND I AGREE I
THINK YOU KNOW GAME. HAVING ONE
IS. OKAY BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BECOME-
DIVERSIFIED IN LOCATIONS
ESPECIALLY I MEAN WHETHER IT'S
URBAN OR RURAL I THINK THAT IS
THE GOAL AND I DON'T WANT TO PUT
WORDS INTO OUR CHAIRS MOUTH. I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE ITEMS
THAT HE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO
IS TO MAKE IT AS CONVENIENT AS
POSSIBLE AND IF YOU'RE IN
TRINITY COUNTY YOU LIVE IN
HAYFORK YOU'RE MOST LIKELY NOT
GOING TO DRIVE. AN HOUR AND
TWENTY MINUTES TO GET TO
WEAVERVILLE TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
RECYCLING I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE AND I AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE A COMMITTED TO THIS
BUT I THINK THAT'S THAT THE
PEACE THAT WE NEED TO E ABLE TO
GET BACK TO. IT THE LAST THING
AT MEADOW DR IF IT'S- ALRIGHT
WITH THE CHAIR LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT SCRAP- AGAIN I DON'T MEAN
TO KEEP BEATING DRUMS SO- BUT IN
RURAL THERE'S A LOT OF SCRAP
METAL. ANDTHERE'S BEEN A REAL
CHALLENGE TO BE ABLE TO REDEEM
THAT RECYCLING CENTERS CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT STRATEGY ON HOW WE
CAN INCLUDE SCRAP. AT THESE
RECYCLING CENTERS AND
INCENTIVIZE CONSUMERS. TO BE A
RETURN THAT AND- I'M SO THANK
YOU QUESTION SENATOR. SO I WILL
SAY AND THEN. CAN PRO IT'S-
QUITE INTEREST. IN AND THAT. AT
YOU KNOW TWENTY PLUS YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS I THINK. HAD THE
MOST AT THE QUICKEST AND MOST
INTERESTING IMPACT. ON AND ON
AND- THE FLUCTUATIONS IN THIS
PARTICULAR FIND IS THE PASSAGE
OF AB SEVEN NINETY THREE WHICH
WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KINGS BELL
ON MINIMUM CONTENTS. AND
REQUIRING MINIMUM CONTENT TO
SCRAP VALUES IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER PROGRAM
HAVE ACTUALLY STABILIZED OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS OR WERE
STARTING TO STEVE'S
DESTABILIZATION AND I THINK THAT
IS BECAUSE- LEGISLATION LIKE
SEVEN NINETY THREE THAT NOW
REQUIRES A MINIMUM. RECYCLED
CONTENT- I'LL AND IT PROVIDES
THE MARKET THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY
THAT THE CERTAINTY OF THAT
PARTICULAR SUPPLY AND THE
CERTAINTY THAT IT WILL BE NEEDED
FOR THE BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT
ARE BEING- BEING- AB RETURNED
RECYCLED AND RE MANUFACTURED. I
THINK ON THE BIGGER PICTURE AS
WE ARE LOOKING AT BUILDING OUT
RECYCLING CENTERS AND INCREASING
THE TYPES OF MATERIALS THAT WE
ARE BRINGING INTO OUR CIRCULAR
ECONOMY I THINK IT WOULD BE
AMAZING. IF WE COULD BUILD THAT
DEVOS IF YOU WELL I'M MORE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MATERIALS I
KNOW ALAMEDA COUNTY HAS WANTED
TO USE THAT IS JUST AMAZING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF THINGS FROM
REVIEWS TO RECYCLE AND I THINK.
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO START
LOOKING AT MODELS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN PLACE THOSE IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE SO THAT THAT
SCRAP IN THOSE- THOSE. THINGS
ARE OUT IN THE WORLD THAT- THAT
PEOPLE ARE HOW A HARD TIME
RECYCLING OUT WE COULD
CONSOLIDATE AND BRING BACK AND
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING TO. TO
BE OF GREAT BENEFIT I THINK
CALIFORNIANS BUT THAT WE COULD
WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON
SO I'M AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING OUT THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY THAT BEAT BEING BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM. IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
CIRCULAR ECONOMY WAS OUR FIRST
RECYCLING PROGRAM IT IS YOU KNOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR REALLY SETTING
THE TONE EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM AND REALLY USING IT
TO BUILD OUT A FULL CIRCULAR
ECONOMY AND GET. TO A PLACE
WHERE EVERY CALIFORNIAN WHEN
THEY THINK ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
THEY USE THINK ABOUT HOW DO I
MAKE IT IT'S NEXT LIFE NOT HOW
DO I THROW IT AWAY IS. OUR
FOREMOST GOAL HERE CAP CYCLE.
THANK YOU KNOW THIS CLOSE WITH
THIS IN TURN IT BACK OVER THE
CHAIR AGAIN I THINK- THERE'S
BEEN AN URGENT NEED URBAN AND
RURAL- I JUST TALK ABOUT RULE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I KNOW- AND-
GRATEFUL TO BEABLE TO GET. THAT
THESE RULES SOME OF THESE RULES
CENTERS RE OPENED- THERE IS BEEN
A PENT UP DEMAND IN NASA
TRACTORS IN THE BEGINNING. THERE
IS LITERALLY A TO OUR QUEUE. TO
GET IN ONCE THE ARCADA FACILITY
OPENED- AND- I DO WANT TO SAY-
THE TRACTOR WAS INTIMATELY
INVOLVED WITH THAT AND JUST WANT
TO SAY. THANK YOU FOR MOVING
THAT FORWARD BECAUSE THAT. I
WON'T SWEAR BUT IT WAS A BIT OF
A SHOW GETTING TO WHERE WE WERE.
ON INTO WHERE IT IS NOW SO DO
APPRECIATE THAT. AND CAN I ALL.
ADD I'M VERY EXCITED THAT. I
DIDN'T NOTICE THAT WE HAD A-
FINE AGAINST- CD ASK- AND WE AND
ACTUALLY DIDN'T- AT COLLECTED
THE FULL PENALTY IS WHAT WE DID
IS WE WORKED WITH CVS. TO
DEVELOP AND I SAT BY SEVERAL
MENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECT
WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO DEPLOY.
AND ON THEIR OWN ADD TWENTY RBM
AT VARIANCE CVS LOCATIONS ACROSS
SOUTH AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ADD TO LOOK AT
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHICS
AND WHERE THEY MAKE SENSE AT
RETAIL THEIR RETAIL FACILITIES
AND ONE OF THEM I BELIEVE IS.
FOR TO NOT. WORKS FURTHER. I
LOVE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INJECTOR THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
ONE K. WAIT TO READ TO FOR
TURNER FOR THE COUNTY FAIR AND
DROP IN THE CVS WITH THE
RECYCLABLES- YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
UNUSUAL PCP WE'VE GOT. ALMOST A
THIRD OF A BILLION DOLLARS ON A
ONE PAGE DESCRIPTION AND I KNOW
ONE OF THE- THINGS WE WANT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE
FUNDING AND EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR INCLUSION IN
THE CURRENT QUIT A PROGRAM FOR
PLASTIC AND GLASS- COULD YOU
PLEASE WALK US THROUGH. THE
ACTIVITIES IN THE ITEMSTHAT
YOU. I MEAN ON THAT ITEM THE
EXPANSION AND- THE BENEFITS OF
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES HAVE HEARD
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT IT NOT
BEING- BEING BENEFICIAL AND
WHAT. THE ADMINISTRATION HOPES
TO ACHIEVE WITH THE FIFTY
MILLION. IN SOME DETAIL.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR WELL THANK
YOU- SO I'M- THE PROPOSAL AS
IT'S TITLED REALLY GOES TO THE
FULL AT CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND ONE
OF THE COMPONENTS OF CIRCULAR
ECONOMY OBVIOUSLY IS NOT ONLY
COLLECTING. THE MATERIALS BACK
BUT GETTING THEM BACK IN SUCH A
WAY. THAT THEY ARE OPTIMALLY
RECYCLED AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- AND THE PRIMARY GOAL OF
THE Q. I. P. PROGRAM IS TO
INCREASE THE OVERALL QUALITY OF
THE MATERIALS THAT WERE GETTING.
AS I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD AT BOTH
HERE IN THE SUB COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS FOR MANY YEARS IN THE
QUEUE. AND THE AMOUNT OF GLASS
CALL IT THAT IS COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA'S GLASS ECYCLING
SYSTEM IS- IS NOT MEETING THE
DEMAND AND SO WE REALLY SEE-
CREATING A HIGHER LEVEL OF
INCENTIVE FOR HIGH QUALITY
GLASS. IN THE RECYCLING PROGRAM
AND REALLY TARGETING SOME OF
THOSE MATERIALS THAT WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS A DEMAND FOR BUT
THAT PERHAPS IS NOT THE HIGHEST.
QUALITY OR IS THAT THAT IS NOT
COMING AND THE AND THAT LEVEL
AND THROUGH THE SYSTEM. TO
REALLY CREATE AN INCENTIVE. TO
DO BETTER IN. MORE OKAY IN THE
B. C. P. THE EMPLOYMENT PLAN
INCLUDES LANGUAGE SAYS HIGHER
GRANT AND LOAN STAFF IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY TWENTY- BUT THERE'S NO
. WEISS INCLUDING THE BCP ARM OR
I DIDN'T SEE ANY P. WEISS
INCLUDING THE PCP- SHOULD THERE
BE SOME WISE OR IN AND IF SO HOW
MANY. YEAH AND. ALL FIVE OF. I
AT SENATOR WE THIS BECAUSE THESE
ARE TIME FINE ARE NOT- ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL- THAT PERSONALLY
YEARS WE ARE GOING TO REDIRECT
EXISTING STAFF- TO HELP
FACILITATE EXPENDITURE OF THESE
FINE. OKAY I'M ALSO IN THE P. C.
P. YOU LIST WATER REFILLING
STATIONS WITH AN IMPLEMENTATION
DATE OF JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO BEGIN SOLICITING GRANT
PROPOSALS HOWEVER I'D ADD ON THE
ONE PAGE PROPOSED PROGRAM
FUNDING- WATER REFILLING
STATIONS ARE NOT LISTED IN YOUR
CHART. IS OUR WATER REFILLING
STATIONS PART OF THIS THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION PROPOSAL
. AND IF SO WHERE ON THE CHART
WITH THE PEOPLE. THEY ARE NOT
SENATOR OUT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THEM AND THEY WERE IN OUR
TIMELINE AS AND I WILL TAKE THE
BLAME FOR THAT I DECIDED TO TAKE
THEM OUT. IS HE IN THE PARCHMENT
INTENDING TO SPEND SOME MONEY ON
THIS FUNCTION. NOT AT THIS TIME
AND ARE OKAY ALTHOUGH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM WAS
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE SO IF
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WITH MIKE AND THE
STAFF. HAPPY TO DISCUSS IT I AT
AND IT IS IN THE ELEVENTH HOUR I
MADE A DECISION. THAT WE WOULD
HAVE THE PROPOSAL- THAT WE PUT
FORWARD TO FINANCE INTO THE
LEGISLATURE- FOCUS ON THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY BUT THAT. IS IN
NO JUDGMENT OF THE VALUE OF.
WATER REFILLING STATIONS. WILL
THERE BE ANY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- TO MEASURE THE.
SUCCESS OF THESE ONE TIME
PROGRAMS THAT YOU HAVE. AND
SENATOR WE'RE ALL. HAPPY TO
REPORT WE DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE I
IN IRAQ I. HAVE A LITTLE
EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT ANYTIME
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO TALK TO
US I'M HAPPY TO COME AND TALK- I
DO NOT SEE HIM ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE AND- AND VALUE OF
THESE FOR HER FAITH WHAT IS HOW
WOULD THE DEPARTMENT MEASURE.
THE SUCCESS OR OF THESE
ACTIVITIES AND- YOU HAVE THE
HUNDRED MILLION- VERSION FOR THE
REDEMPTION THAT'S GONNA LAST
FOUR TO EIGHT WEEKS- COMPARED
TO. MUCH SMALLER AMOUNTS THAT
TWO MILLION TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO ESTABLISH-
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHTS
OF INFRASTRUCTURE APPEARS TO BE
YOU KNOW THAT'S A BIGGER LONG
TERM BENEFIT HOW WOULD YOU.
MEASURE THAT SUCCESS OF THAT THE
HUNDRED MILLION. IN THE-
INCREASED. OF REDEMPTION VALUE.
OR RETURN VALUE. YOU'RE SPEAKING
TO THAT CONSUMER CREDIT- I THINK
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY SOME CRITERIA
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS
THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO DISCUSS THAT
OUR OVERALL METRICS THAT WE-
MEASURE SUCCESS. IN THE CONTEXT
OF THIS PROGRAM IS HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAD ACCESS TO THIS
PROGRAM THAT DIDN'T PREVIOUSLY
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM HOW
MANY BEVERAGE CONTAINERS FOR WE
ADULTS YOU- COLLECT THAT WE
BELIEVE WE WOULDN'T HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN ABLE TO- COLLECT-
AND- AND WHETHER OR NOT
CONSUMERS. FELT THAT- THEY HAD
ACHIEVED WHAT WAS AGAIN I
BELIEVE RIGHTLY THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THEIR- THEIR
REDEMPTION VALUE BACK OUT OF
THEIR BEVERAGE CONTAINER. TO
THIS DEPARTMENT HAVE A NUMBER I
KNOW. AND I'M GOING BACK TO
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE
OF THE COVE IT- THERE WAS. I
HEARD REPORTS THAT THAT THE
HAULERS WERE NOT RECYCLING
ANYTHING BECAUSE OF HEALTH
CONCERNS AND THEY WERE JUST
TAKING EVERYTHING OFF TO THE-
THE LANDFILL I DON'T I DON'T I
CAN'T CONFIRM WHETHER THAT'S
TRUE OR NOT BUT WOULDN'T THAT.
AFFECT THE RECYCLING RATE IF
THEY THINGS JUST WENT TO
REGRETTABLY TO THE LANDFILL
ADMITTEDLY FOR HEALTH REASONS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA ON THAT.
WELL SENATOR AT. WE'D THAT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HEARD
HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT NOT FROM
CALLERS NOT FROM RECYCLERS SO I
WOULD BE CURIOUS FOR THAT'S
COMING AND I WOULD SAY- THAT WE
ARE NOT SEEING IN OUR WEEK
CHARACTERIZATIONS THAT WE ARE
DOING AT THAT AT RIGHT NOW
WHICH- WHICH WILL COME OUT. I
BELIEVE. LATER THIS YEAR- WE ARE
NOT SEEING RECYCLABLE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS- EIGHT AND INCREASED
NUMBER OF RECYCLED FULL COVERAGE
CONTAINERS SHOWING UP IN
LANDFILLS WHICH IS WHY WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE. THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON AT I JUST DIDN'T
BRING THEM BACK TO RECYCLING
CENTERS- BUT WE HAVE NOT SEEN A
HUGE INFLUX OF BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS IN LANDFILLS BUT WHEN
THAT WHEN ARE WE FAIR THURSDAY
XIN STUDY COMES OUT OF THE SURE
TO. AND WE GET TO THAT- COPY IT
WAS HARD TO SAY WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
RECYCLING CENTERS WERE CLOSED.
AS WE ALL KNOW LIKE MOST OTHER
BUSINESSES- AND AT AND- THE
TRANSFER FACILITIES FEDERAL
CLOSED WITH THAT WE'RE NOT
SEEING IN OUR DATA COLLECTION-
THAT PLAY OUT. SENATE W. HAD A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WELL I JUST
WANTED. THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY.
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN IS ONE TIME SO WHO
WHO IS THE INTENDED RECIPIENTS I
MEAN AT ALL AND WHAT FACTORS WE
- RECONSIDERING AND PRIOR TO OUR
PRIVATE. PARADISE IN PROJECTS TO
FUND. SO THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
REALLY THE MAIN TENETS AND
PRINCIPLES THAT WE EMPLOYED AS
WE WERE DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL
WHAT IS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
CONSUMER BEHAVIORS ARE LIKE
REALLY TO CHANGE AGAIN AND SO
THIS WE ARE TREATING THIS AS ONE
TIME FUNDING WITH AN EXPECTATION
THAT THINGS COULD VERY WELL
CHANGE IN SIX MONTHS TO TWELVE
MONTHS AGAIN- BUT OUR NUMBER ONE
PRINCIPLE WAS. THERE ARE AND
ROUGHLY 42% OF THE CONVENIENCE
DOWN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY SIR AND
OUR PRIORITY IS TO SERVE EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA AND HAVE EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UTILIZE THIS
PROGRAM AND SO AS YOU WILL SEE-
WE DEPLOY A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SYSTEMS. AND THE SECOND
PRINCIPLE THAT WE- HAVE AT ARE
ABIDING BY IN THIS PROPOSAL IS
WE WANT TO DO IT NOW WE DON'T
WANT TO- SPENT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
ON EACH AND EVERY RECYCLING
CENTER AS WE ARE PURSUING MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS IN THE
SYSTEM AS WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON STATUTORY
CHANGES THAT GIVE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY WE WANT TO HOPE TO
PLAY SOLUTIONS. NOW OVER THE
NEXT YEAR E WANTED TO FOR A
MOBILE RECYCLING TO PLACES LIKE
ALPINE AND TRINITY COUNTY WHERE
A RECYCLING CENTER IS GOING TO
BE VERY DIFFICULT. A RECYCLING
CENTER AND NUMBER OF RECYCLING
CENTERS WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO DEPLOY SO IF WE CAN PROVIDE A
MOBILE SOLUTION WHERE EVERY
CALIFORNIANS CAN UTILIZE IT OVER. THE COURSE OF A MONTH- AND FOR
THE YEARS TO COME. AND REALLY
SHOW HOW THAT KIND OF SYSTEM
COULD WORK FOR OUR WORLD PARTS
OF OUR STATE THAT IS REALLY
ULTIMATELY ARE. HOW MANY
PROJECTS WITH THIS PART OF
MONEY. EXPECT TO FIND. SO FOR
THE MOBILE RECYCLING WE ARE
PROPOSING SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND I THINK FOR BREAKING
THAT DOWN REGIONALLY INTO FOUR
REGIONS OF THE STATE WITH LIKE
BE WHAT WE WOULD PROPOSE AND IT
WOULD ALLOW US TO THEN AT. THE
SAME TIME DEPLOYED ACROSS THE
STATE AT FOUR DIFFERENT AT-
SYSTEMS SO REALLY ULTIMATELY
HITTING EVERY RECYCLING DOES OR
IN THE STATE. THAT COUPLED WITH
THE AD DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING FOR REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES AND AGAIN THIS IS A
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS NOT BEEN
WIDELY BEFORE EVEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO. WE WANT TO DO
IT IN A WAY THAT- TEST THE
THEORY- BUT ALSO PROVIDE ACCESS
SO WE ARE PROPOSING ROUGHLY TWO
THOUSAND- TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND OF REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES BEING DEPLOYED- WITH
THE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS THAT
IS PROPOSED IN THIS- AND THIS
PROPOSAL- OVER IT THAT NEXT YEAR
OR SO- AND- I THINK. ALLOWING
THOSE WITH THEN AGAIN FROM
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS- REALLY HELPING TO
VERY VERY QUICKLY AND
IMMEDIATELY DEPLOYED SOME
SOLUTIONS FOR THE PLACES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY ACCESS BUT I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE MOBILE
RECYCLING AGAINST. OUT LIKE
YOU'RE GROWING UP IN A IN A
RURAL PART OF THE STATE TO YOUR
POINT YOU KNOW THAT YOU YOU
COULD BE IN ONE PART OF TRINITY
COUNTY. AND THE RECYCLING CENTER
COULD BE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT CERTAINLY ISN'T CONVENIENT
SO WE REALLY WANT TO DO THIS IN
A WAY THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
ADEQUATE CONVENIENCE TO EVERY
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ANT TO WORK
WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- OUR RETAIL
PARTNERS- IN FIGURING OUT SO
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS THAT WORK
FOR THE. POPULATIONS OF PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO SERVE. SO I JUST
WANTED ARE CLOSED THE LAST.
COMMENT I THE CHERUB UP THE REAR
GOOD POINT IT. THERE SHOULD BE.
REPORTING IN THIS THERE'S A LOT
OF MONEY. AND WE NEED TO KNOW-
YOU KNOW WHO'S GETTING THE WHO'S
GETTING THE CONTRACTS AND HOW
THE MONEY IS BEING SPENT. AND
THEN HOW WHAT THE FACTS ARE-
BECAUSE THIS ONE TIME MONIES AND
IN SOME THE LIFESPAN TO SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS OR- CREDITORS
LIKE FORTY WEEKS. SO I THINK THE
IT WOULD BE BEHOOVE THE-
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT- PUT IN THIS. IT
GOES FORWARD. OKAY LET'S LET'S
PICK UP ON THE- SEVENTY MILLION
TO ESTABLISH THE- MOBILE
RECYCLING AND RURAL OR
UNDERSERVED- WE DO HAVE A
CURRENT PILOT PROGRAMS FOR. UP
BOB MOBILE RECYCLING. WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THOSE PROGRAMS- AT
CAL RECYCLE AND- HOW DO YOU SEE
THEM BEING PLACED INTO THESE
FOUR DIFFERENT REGIONS MORE.
LESSONS LEARNED. SO I THINK THAT
WAS A REALLY EXCELLENT I'M POINT
THAT ROSTER BROUGHT UP AND OUR
MOBILE RECYCLER IN AND IN CULVER
CITY HAS BEEN OPERATING FOR.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ONE OF OUR
LONGER AND LOCAL RECYCLERS I
THINK CENTS TWENTY TWENTY AND SO
FAR THEY ARE CURRENTLY SERVING
INTO. A FOLDER CITY- AND- NUMBER
OF CONTAINERS THAT THEY WERE
DEEMED THROUGH THE MOBILE
RECYCLING IS ROUGHLY FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION- AYE CONTAINERS AYE
RECYCLED AYE BETWEEN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY AND MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. I'M SO I THINK IF
THE QUESTION IS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO INCREASE OUR RECYCLING
RATE SIGNIFICANTLY I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SATISFIED WITH THE MOBILE
RECYCLING OR ANY OF THESE OTHER
SYSTEMS- I THAT WE ARE TESTING
IN SOME OF OUR RECYCLING CENTERS
IF THE QUESTION IS DID WE
INCREASE ACCESS AND DO THE
CONSUMERS- AND PEOPLE OF THAT
LOCATION FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
GREATER ACCESS. I THINK THAT YOU
WOULD GET A SIGNIFICANT ANSWER
OF THE PEOPLE OF CULVER CITY
HAVE BEEN VERY HAPPY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR SYSTEM AND ARE
LOOKING TO EXPAND SO I THINK YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
WORTH NOTING IN TERMS AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAD VERY
SIGNIFICANT DECREASES. IN THE
NUMBER OF RECYCLING CENTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- AND
THAT THAT THAT QUESTION CALLS
INTO QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE PROVIDED ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
THIS PROGRAM BUT WHAT DID HAPPEN
IS EACH TIME WE LOST HUNDREDS OF
RECYCLING CENTERS OUR RECYCLING
RATE ONLY WENT DOWN ONE TO THREE
PERCENT. SO IT'S IN THESE AREAS
WERE NOT NECESSARILY UP
RECYCLING HUGE QUANTITIES IT IS
REALLY JUST ENSURING OVERALL
ACCESS TO A PROGRAM THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO. RIGHT
OKAY I MEAN BECAUSE NO CULVER
CITY IS A DENSE POPULATION URBAN
AREA AND YOUR PREVIOUS REMARKS
ABOUT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IN
THE RURAL AREAS THE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS THAT THAT
THAT HAS TO GO IN AND THE
SCARCITY. OF THE SCARCITY SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. ARE
THERE LINKAGES BETWEEN THE PILOT
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE RUNNING
RIGHT NOW THAT WILL DO BEST
PRACTICES OR- IS THIS ENTIRELY.
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT PROGRAM FROM
ALL THE CURRENT MOBILE PROGRAM
SAID THAT WE HAD. THAT IS A
REALLY GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU
CENTER I WE'RE GOING TO BE
TREATING THIS OR WE WOULD
PROPOSE TREATING THEM.
DIFFERENTLY THAN B. FROM THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WERE RUNNING
AT THAT ARE BEING RUN BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE THIS IS- OF A FIRST FOR
CALIFORNIA WOULD THAT WE WOULD
BE CONTRACTING DIRECTLY. WITH
RECYCLING AND ENTITIES- AND WHAT
WE REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON IS
HELPING BUILD OUT AND STATE AND
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORES OUT
REALLY BUILDING OUT A DEMAND FOR
THIS KIND OF- AT OPPORTUNITY IN
THESE REGIONS BUT WE WANT TO
REALLY THE REASON WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DOING FOUR. SEPARATE
PROJECTS NOT PROJECTS BUT REPORT
A DIFFERENT TEAMS IF YOU WELL
AND IS REALLY YOU KNOW WHAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING. FOR READING
AND CRESCENT CITY I AND- I. JUST
THE ENTIRETY OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE NEED TO
DO FOR SANTA MONICA OR ADD YOU
KNOW USING THE EXAMPLE OF CULVER
CITY AND SO WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO DO IS TAKE WHAT WE KNOW AT
THE STATE LEVEL. ABOUT WHAT IS
WORKING FROM THE PILOT PROJECTS
BUT JUST IN GENERAL AND DEPLOYS
SOME SOME IDEAS AROUND AND IT IN
REALLY INSTITUTING SOME OF THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO SHOW YOU ALL
OKAY YOU NEED SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT IN CRESCENT CITY THAN
WHAT YOU NEED AND FRESNO. SO
HERE IS HOW WE CAN DEVISE- A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS. FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF CALIFORNIA PROTECTED
THAT SOUNDS GOOD IT JUST IT
CREATES SOME IT DOESN'T SEEM
CONGRUENT WITH THE OTHER LINE
ITEM FOR TWO MILLION THAT YOU
HAVE FOR AUTHORITY TEN SENTIFI
IS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES THAT
SORT OF. IT'S A LOAN NOT A GRANT
AND IT WOULD SEEM LIKE IF YOU
WENT OUT TO THESE AREAS SHE'S
RURAL AREAS AND SOMETHING THINK
SEEM TO. WORK YOU'D WANT TO HAVE
THAT HAND IN HEY THE AUTHORITY
SAY LET'S DO SOME MORE PER. OR
YOU KNOW- TO YOU KNOW TO. SIR
WRIST CENTER WE GOT LUCKY- SO
THOSE TO THE TO THE- GIVEN YOUR
EXPLANATION YOU WOULD THINK THAT
YOU WOULD WANT MORE MONEY IN.
OTHER THAN TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A LOAN VERSUS A GRANT OR
SOME OTHER SORT OF INCENTIVE TO
BUILD THAT INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN
SOMETHING GOES RIGHT AND ONE OF
THESE FOUR REGIONS. JUST A
THOUGHT CENTER DOLLY HAS A
QUESTION AGAIN. OKAY DO THEY
HAVE THE FLEET REQUIRED FOR THE
MOBILE SERVICES LIKE LIKE HOW
MUCH- OF THIS WOULD GO TOWARDS
ACQUIRING NEW VEHICLES AND
UPGRADING EQUIPMENT TO MEET THE
MOBILE SOURCE. AND HOW MUCH WILL
IT IMPACT RECYCLING RATES- CARDS
MOBILE SORT A SOURCE
REQUIREMENTS. AND STILL ACTUALLY
AT AS SENATOR BECAUSE WE WOULD
BE CONTACTING FOR THIS WE WOULD
NOT BE USING ANY OF THESE FUNDS
TO ACTUALLY PURCHASE. ANY
VEHICLES WE ARE LOOKING TO-
CONTRACT. AND THE CONTRACTORS
ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO MEET
THE EMISSION STANDARDS IN MOBILE
SOURCE IMPACTS OF CARP. ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF AND INDUSTRY AND
PLATE- THEY WOULD HAVE TO MEET
ALL CURRENT LAWS AND REGULATIONS
. BUT WE ARE NOT ADDING ANY
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS HERE. SO
ON THE SEVENTY MILLION FOR THE
RURAL AREAS ARE THOSE LOANS OR
GRANTS THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
GIVEN OUT. FOR THE MOBILE THE
MOBILE RECYCLING CORRECT THOSE
ARE CONTRACTS OKAY THOSE
CONTRACTS AND YOU YOU TO
SUBMISSION FOR REGIONS SHOULD WE
MOM IS THAT COULD BE FOR
CONTRACTS OR IS THERE GOING TO
BE SUBCONTRACTS WITHIN A REGION
IN CALIFORNIA. STILL PART OF THE
REASON I KNOW- RUSS'S YEARLY
NOTED THAT THAT PART OF THE
REASON THAT WE DIDN'T GO INTO
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROVISION ALL OF THE
P. C. P. IS THAT WE WANT TO DO A
PUBLIC PROCESS THAT INCLUDES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- RECYCLERS-
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
DETERMINE THE BEST WAY TO- CHIU
AND MAYBE IT ENDS UP BEING FIVE
REGIONS. THAT IN MY MIND I CAN
KIND OF SEE THAT THE FOR BUT THE
BEST WAY TO DEVISE A SYSTEM THAT
WORKS FOR ALL OF THE RURAL AREAS
OF THE STATE SO WE REALLY WANT
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND DEVISE A SYSTEM
THAT THAT WORKS. WHAT ACT THAT
NOW WHAT FACTORS WITH CAL
RECYCLE BE USING IN THE
TERMINATING THE FUNDING. FOR
THESE RECIPIENTS OR- HELLO. THE
PRIORITIES FOR THE RECIPIENTS.
WELL THE PERSON FOR MOST- FACTOR
AND SENATOR AS WE DISCUSSED IS
HOW IS THIS GOING TO PRODUCE-
NOTICEABLE INCREASES IN- AND
MEANINGFUL. AND INCREASES IN
ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM- OR AS
WORLD CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY IN
THOSE RECYCLING DESERT-AND LIKE
I SAID WE WOULD LIKE TO SET UP A
PUBLIC PROCESS BY WHICH WE WOULD
DEVELOP A CONTRACTING CRITERIA.
WHERE WE WOULD THEN PUT THE
CONTRACT OUT TO BID- BUT ALSO
GIVING CREDIT BUT BY ALSO GIVING
PRIORITY TO OUR CONSERVATION
FOREST- AND THE STATE COURT. I'M
ON THE LET'S MOVE TO THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE REVERSE
VENDING MACHINES IN PARTICULAR
THE FIFTY MILLION FOR HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES. WHY NOT.
WHY COLLEGES AND HIGH SCHOOLS
AND WHY NOT YOU KNOW PUBLIC
FORMS THAT HAVE A BETTER. OF
BROADER SPECTRUM OF- OF FOLKS
LIKE A LIBRARY OR COMMUNITY
CENTER OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BECAUSE OF THE- ANTICIPATED.
CHALLENGES YOU MAY HAVE ON GOING
ON TO A- ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SITE.
IT'S FUNNY THAT YOU WELL IF WE
DID NOT PROPOSED. ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. BUT I THAT YOU THAT
BECAUSE I IT WAS A CONVERSATION
THAT I HAD WITH YOU WHERE- AND
LIBRARIES WAS BROUGHT UP I DON'T
I CAN'T REMEMBER BUT I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT LIBRARIES. AND I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT ADDITION TO
THIS WHAT THE REAL IDEA THOUGH
BEHIND UNIVERSITIES AND HIGH
SCHOOLS AS THAT BECAUSE- THEY
HAVE- TYPICALLY HAVE BENDING
MACHINES ON SITE WOULDN'T IT BE
GREAT. I F. AS A UNIVERSITY
STUDENT OR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
AFTER YOU FINISHED YOUR BOTTLE
OF WATER IF YOU COULD PUT IT
DIRECTLY INTO YOUR OVERSPENDING
MACHINE AND THAT THAT MONEY WENT
INTO. A COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT
THAT YOU SET UP OR DAY- HIGH
SCHOOL COULD BE DOING SOME FORM
OF CHARITY DRIVE AND PEOPLE
COULD BE BRINGING. THEIR BOTTLES
AND CANS FROM HOME AND DOING
CHARITY THERE SO WHAT WE WERE
REALLY DOING IS YOU KNOW ART THE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
REALLY GOING TO BE THE ONES THAT
LEAD THIS NATION AND EVERYTHING.
BUT I REALLY IN THIS CASE THEY
ARE VERY AT ENVIRONMENTALLY.
AWARE AND WHY NOT BUILD ON THAT
BY PROVIDING THEM THE TECHNOLOGY
AT TO BENEFIT FROM THE SYSTEM SO
WASN'T REALLY INTENDED TO HAVE
PEOPLE WALKING ONTO UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES ARE HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IT WAS REALLY INTENDED
FOR THE POPULATIONS THAT ARE
NORMALLY ON THOSE FACILITY FEEL
LIKE THOSE BUT I LOVE THE IDEA.
OF EXPANDING THAT TO OTHER
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS LIKE- LIKE
LIBRARIES SO THE INTENDED
REDEEMER WILL BE LIKE ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS JUST A COLLEGE
STUDENT THERE'S. NO OTHER
THERE'S NO OTHER. DO EIGHT.
RIGHT RIGHT I MEAN IF YOU THINK
I LIKE A I THINKING AS I. AND
CITY COLLEGE. HOW MANY. OF RE
COMING AND GOING FROM A CITY
COLLEGE CAMPUS EVERY DAY AND
WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT IF THEY HAD
ACCESS TO THIS TECHNOLOGY RIGHT
THERE. AGAIN THE IDEA OF
EXPANDING IT TO OTHER PUBLIC
FACILITIES YOU HAVE FIFTY
MILLION FOR SUPERMARKETS- HOW
DID YOU ARRIVE AT THAT FIGURE
FOR SUPPORT THAT'S A THOUSAND
MACHINES FOR ALL THE
SUPERMARKETS IN THESE
UNDERSERVED. RURAL URBAN AND
SUBURBAN AREAS. SENATOR AS WE
WORK I'M WORKING THROUGH THE
DISCUSSIONS- WITH OUR- NOW
PARTNER OVER AT CVS WE WERE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THE PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT ARE. NOT
ADEQUATELY SERVED AND LOOKING AT
ALL OF THEIR PARTICULAR SITE
BECAUSE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THEIR SETTLEMENT BUT WE STARTED
LOOKING AT GROCERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. AS A YOU KNOW A
THOUSAND- REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES AT GROCERY STORES IS A
SIGNIFICANT DEPLOYMENT THAT
ALLOWS US TO TRULY TEST WHETHER
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD BE
UTILIZED STATEWIDE. BUT ALSO-
NOT SO OF SO MANY THAT WE WOULD.
BE AT A STRUGGLING TO- PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT. I THE
MILLION THE WE HAVE FOR YOU
PROPOSE FOR START UP LOANS I'VE
TALKED TO ADVOCATES AND DAVE
KRIEG THEY'VE SHARED WITH ME A
MODEL THAT- OF ENTERPRISE WOULD
NEED SOMETHING IN THE ORDER OF
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH.
FOR A THIRTY SIX MONTH PERIOD IN
ORDER TO IN IN ONE OF THESE AS
YOU ARE POINTED OUT IN ARCADIA
ONE OF THESE CHALLENGED AREAS
TO. BUY THE EQUIPMENT SERVICE A
PROCESSOR AND GET AND GET THE
TYPE OF IN THE SERVICE TO THE-
COMMUNITY THAT'S THERE- AND YOU
KNOW I. SORT OF. LIVE THE DREAM
OF BEING A RECYCLER PROCESSOR IN
THIS AREA- YOU GUYS. IT APPEARS
TO BE THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS AS
PROPOSED IN THE B. C. P. IS. A
RATHER LOW NUMBER AND IT'S A
LOAN FOR PARTICIPATION- COMPARED
TO THE IN THE HUNDRED MILLION TO
THAT REACHED RICHARD. HOW DID
YOU LAND ON THAT AND WHAT TYPE
OF RESULTS DO YOU EXPECT. WITH
THAT WITH THAT TYPE OF MONEY.
THE REASON THAT WE STRUCTURED
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE OF THE
PROPOSAL THE WAY THAT WE DID
SENATOR WHAT IS THAT WILL WIND
IT IS LOANS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE EXPENDITURE OF
THE FUNDS. IS AT IT PROCREATE
EXPENDITURE AND STATE DOLLARS
AND SO IT IS A FORGIVABLE LOAN
AS IT STRUCTURED BUT IT IS ALSO
INTENDED TO BE A START UP COST
AND NOT BE AN ONGOING
SENSITISATION OF THE RECYCLING
CENTER. ONE OF THAT I THINK
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE NOTING
HERE IS THAT IT WOULD BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT TO HOW THEY HAVE A
RECYCLING CENTER. AND AT
SIGNIFICANT COST TO HAVE A
RECYCLING CENTER AT SUBSIDIZED
IN SOME OF THESE AREAS AND
REGIONS OF THE STATE AND AS
THESE ARE ONE TIME FUNDS WE
CAN'T CONTINUE THE
SUBSIDIZATION. OVER THE LIFE OF
THE RECYCLING CENTER AND SO WE
DON'T WANT TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT CAN'T SUSTAIN ITSELF SO THE
INTENTION HERE WAS TO PROVIDE. A
START UP COSTS AND FOR THOSE
RECYCLERS WHO HAD A BUSINESS
MODEL WHERE THE WHAT THEY REALLY
TRULY NEEDED WAS FOR. START UP
COSTS WE WOULD HELP SUBSIDIZE
THE START UP COSTS BUT THAT THE
BUSINESS MODEL INTO ITSELF WOULD
HAVE TO WORK- I'VE ITS EVENTS EL
MOMENTO VENTILATION SO. I'M AND
THEN AGAIN IF THEY ARE LOANS SO
THAT WE HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO
RECRUIT THOSE DOLLARS IF THEY
ARE NOT APPROPRIATELY EXPENDED.
AND WHEN YOU SEE APPROPRIATELY
EXPENDED THE MAIN I'VE SUGGESTED
THAT THEY STAY IN BUSINESS FOR
THREE YEARS. SO THAT THEY THEY
HAVE SOME. ACCRUED TO- THE
KICKED THE COMMUNITY AND THEN
GIVING THEM THIS FORGIVABLE LOAN
TO STAY IN BUSINESS WILL BE
BUILT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE DO YOU
HAVE HAVE YOU TALKED IT. ACTUAL
INVESTORS OR INVESTORS THAT
WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT MODEL OR
DIFFERENT. NO THAT'S VERY
CONSISTENT SENATOR WENT WELL
WHAT THEY'VE TALKED ABOUT ALSO-
YOU KNOW I WOULD ADD TO THAT-
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT AS THOSE
FACILITIES WOULD NEED TO BE DONE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY WERE
OPERATING CONSISTENT WITH OFF
OKAY LAST QUESTION FOR ME- AT
THE END OF A- PAGE SEVENTEEN OF
OUR STAFF REPORT. WE TALK ABOUT
THE LIMITATIONS OF THE BOTTLE
BILL AND CAL RECYCLE PUBLISHED
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN- THE
PUBLICATION OF THE PROGRAM IT'S
LIMITED ABILITIES XCERRA WE
TALKED ABOUT. IMPROVING
RECYCLING AND MANUFACTURING
SHARING RESPONSIBILITIES THAT'S
A GOOD AND INTERESTING THOUGHT
AND ENHANCING ADAPT ADAPTABILITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY IN BETWEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TODAY WE
HAD. REPLANTED CLOSING ITS TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR.
LOCATIONS HOW DOES THIS PROPOSAL
RESPOND TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CAL. RECYCLED
PUBLICATION. WELL I THINK YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT HAD
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS INCORPORATED
SOME OF THE CONCEPTS TO THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN- WHITE PAPER
THAT THE DEPARTMENT PUT OUT AT
THAT JUNCTURE. I HAVEN'T SITTING
HERE SOMEPLACE WHAT PAPER AND SO
I WOULD SAY FIRST AND FOREMOST I
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHITE PAPER
RECOMMENDED- DOING SOME PILOT
PROJECTS TO TEST SOME MORE
FLEXIBLE SOLUTIONS SO AS YOU AND
AS WE DISCUSSED AND AS YOU ALL
WELL KNOW WE ARE DOING THAT
RIGHT NOW IS A STATE AND ACROSS
MANY DIFFERENT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- OVERALL
SUSTAINABILITY WITHIN THE SYSTEM
AND I THINK YOU WILL ALSO KNOW
IN THE IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHITE PAPER THERE ARE SOME
STATUTORY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
AT THAT- THAT TO BE AT WHAT YOU
WERE MADE AS IN ADDITION TO. THE
WERE THAT WE IN TWENTY TWENTY AB
PURSUANT TO AB AT FIFTY FOUR AND
I THINK THE OVERALL THEME OF
THOSE VIEWS THE WHITE PAPER AND
THE AB FIFTY FOUR REPORT IS THAT
THERE ARE SOME- CHANGES THAT
SHOULD BE MADE TO THIS PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY I
TO DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
AS THE NEEDS ARE DEMANDED BY THE
PEOPLE IN THOSE PARTS OF THE
STATE AND I THINK THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY GOES TO THAT FIGHT
AGAINST MOBILE RECYCLING IN
PARTS OF THE STATE DEPLOYING
MOBILE RECYCLING IN PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE I HAVE RECYCLING
CENTER. PERHAPS AT AND ISN'T
GOING TO BE PROFITABLE OVER THE
LONG TERM DEPLOYING RPM'S CHIP
GROCERS WHO WANT TO BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION BUT DON'T HAVE THE
REAL ESTATE OUR RECYCLING THAT-
RECYCLER LARGE BINS AND A LOT IN
THEIR PARKING LOT WHAT ARE SOME
OTHER THINGS WHERE WE CAN BE
MORE FLEXIBLE FOR THE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF. THE STATE OF THAT ARE
THAT ARE- HAVING TOWN AND DO WE
INSTILL THAT FLEX OF. INTO INTO
OUR SYSTEM TO INCREASE OVERALL
RECYCLE BUT NO OF FOR TAKE
ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM. RIGHT- I
GUESS I'LL JUST NOTE THAT THE
SHARED RESPONSIBILITIES WHICH IS
A KEY COMPONENT OF THE REPORT
JUST SEEMS TO- NOT GET ADDRESS
ONE LAST QUESTION- THE THERE'S
NO PROPOSALS THAT ADDRESS
HANDLING FEES IS SIR. A REASON
THAT SEEMS TO BE A CONTINUING-
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE OR A
CONCERT A CONCERNED A COMPLAINT
. YET AGAIN AND- THE PRIMARY
TENANT OR ONE OF THE PRIMARY
TENANTS OF THIS PROPOSAL FOR IS
THAT A RECOGNITION THAT THIS IS
LIKELY ONE TIME FUNDING ALLEN BY
USING THESE DOLLARS TO REFORM
THE HANDLING FEES- THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A FROM. CREATE A NEW
EXPECTATION THAT CAN ONLY BE
USED WITH AND STATE TEAMS
PERMANENTLY OUT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING HERE TO DO IS REALLY
AGAINST PROVIDE GREATER ACCESS
TO THE SYSTEM- TESTING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND NEW THEORIES IN
PARTS OF THE STATE AND
HISTORICALLY BEEN. UNDERSERVED
OR DIFFICULT TO SERVE AND
PROVIDE EVERYTHING ALL
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO THE
SYSTEM TOMORROW- AND WE REALLY
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU SENATOR ON
HOW CAN WE USE THESE DOLLARS- TO
BEST CREATE LONG TERM INJURY-
HIS SOLUTIONS- AND- I THINK AT
WHAT WE PUT FORWARD IS EIGHTY- A
VERY. STRONG PROPOSAL TO DO SO.
MISTER BROWN THE DAILY- YOU'VE
LISTENED TO THIS. CALL OUR
DISCUSSION FOR AN HOUR PLUS YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. I THINK THE
MAIN- IT UP SOME OF THE MAIN A
KIND OF IMPORTANT ISSUES I THINK
WE'VE HEARD IS THAT I MEAN ONE-
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND IT IS ONE TIME MONEY
AND SO- AND THERE'S ALSO SORT OF
I THINK IN MANY CASES JUST.
LIMITED INFORMATION ABOUT KIND
OF WHAT THE ACTUAL OUTCOMES ARE
GOING TO BE- AND IN MANY CASES
IT'S SORT OF EXPANDING ON.
HIGHLIGHTS THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE BUT MAYBE WE JUST DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF GREAT INFORMATION
OR DETAIL LONG KIND OF LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THOSE AND WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT THE OUTCOMES OF
THEM AND SO. I THINK WE WERE
JUST SORT OF- SUGGESTED THE
LEGISLATURE- THINK ABOUT KIND OF
. WHERE OR HOW MUCH IT WANTS TO
KIND OF ALLOCATE TO THESE NEW
ACTIVITIES WITH THAT LIMITED
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION- WITH AN
EYE TOWARDS ANOTHER COMMENT
SURROUNDS YOUR REPORTING AND
TRYING TO GET GOOD INFORMATION
ABOUT. WHAT THOSE OUTCOMES.
ACTUALLY WILL BE IF THEY GET
FUNDED AND SO MAKING SURE THAT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS THAT.
TYPE OF OVERSIGHT REPORTING.
WHATEVER ACTIONS IT TAKES SO
THEY CAN HAVE BEEN INFORMATION
ABOUT ITS DECISIONS GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER. MISS
WAGNER ARE DIRECTOR WAGNER
DEPUTY. DIRECTOR OF MCINTYRE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE WILL
NOW MOVE- TO ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM. ONE TWO ZERO ZERO WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE PART OF
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE COME
FORWARD. AS A REMINDER TO THESE
PARTICIPATION NUMBER FOR THOSE-
PROVIDING COMMENT-
TELEPHONICALLY WOULD BE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. OF. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO AND DO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LINK LINK THE
FAIRINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY. I'M GOING TO
LISTEN TO THE. THE ASSEMBLAGE-
IS PROCEED. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHASE AND I
WITH THAT'LL STING ROPES AND
SMITH ON BASS OF THE GLOW
PACKAGING AND JUST WANTED TO
OFFER HANG ON WE GOT IT WE'RE
NOT- NOT PICKING UP THE SOUND.
IF YOU COULD START OVER YEAH NO
PROBLEM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I COMING THROUGH NOW.
NO. OKAY HOW BOUT NOW. HEY TONY
HERE YOU. OKAY OVER HERE WITHOUT
BOXES YEAH. COME BEHIND THE BAR. REGULAR MAKING EXTRA EXCEPTION
HERE- SO IS THIS ONE S. TEST
TEST MAYBE I JUST NEED TO GET
CLOSER TO THE MIKE THE WHOLE
TIME BUT I'M GLAD TO BE BACK
HERE WITH ALL OF YOU KNOW THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO AGAIN J.
SNACKING ON BEHALF OF THE GLASS
PACKAGING INSTITUTE JUST WANTED
TO OFFER A COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON
THE DISCUSSION THAT YOU ALL JUST
HAD AND REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT
BECAUSE WHILE WE WELCOME
INVESTMENTS IN THE PROGRAM. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THE DETAILS AS WE
ALL DISCUSS REALLY DO MATTER-
AND AS A GENERAL PROPOSITION G.
P. I BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALLOCATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
BY BACK INFRASTRUCTURE BUT AT A
HIGH LEVEL A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
ON THE ON THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS
THAT ARE INCLUDED HERE FIRST GPI
IS OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED
INCREASE IN REDEMPTION PAYMENTS
IS SIMPLY BELIEVE THAT THAT
THEY'RE BETTER INVESTMENTS FOR
THAT MONEY THAT THERE ARE BETTER
WAYS TO PUT IT TO GOOD USE. I'M
ON THE ISSUE OF FUNDING FOR
REVERSE VENDING MACHINES IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE THOSE
MACHINES BE SUPPORTED BY IT BY A
RECYCLER IF NOT YOU'RE
COLLECTING MATERIAL THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY COME BACK AND OR
RATHER IT'LL SIT THERE. ON
MOBILE RECITE. YOU KNOW IT SEEMS
LIKE A VERY PROMISING THING. BUT
WE ARE WAITING TO SEE YOU YOU
KNOW THE ALTERNATE OUTCOMES OF
THE EXISTING PILOTS. IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS- YOU KNOW BAG
DROPS MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE
INVESTMENT TO MAKE. AND LASTLY
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY FOR THE FOR
THE GLASS PACKAGING INSTITUTE WE
REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH CAL
RECYCLE IN THE LEGISLATURE ON ON
QUALITY INCENTIVE PAYMENTS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE Q. I. P. NOT
SUBSIDIZE BUSINESS WOULD USE AS
USUAL WE NEED TO HAVE HIGH
QUALITY. GLASS ARE RECYCLABLE
GLASS THAT COMES OUT OF THAT
PAYMENT- AND SO AGAIN WE'RE
WE'RE READY TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND WORK ON THAT WITH
YOU BUT I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER THESE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE EX. A GOOD MORNING KYLE
JONES WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER AND I WANTED TO SPEAK ON
ISSUE SIX ON THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION PROPOSAL FOR- THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT AND WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW NOT PROVIDING
THAT EXEMPTION COULD IMPACT THE
WORKLOAD OVER THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WE
SUPPORT THE NEW POSITIONS THAT
ARE BEING PROPOSED TO IMPLEMENT
SIGMA- BUT WE'RE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE- THERE'S THIRTY
FOUR PLANS THAT ARE CURRENTLY.
CONSIDERED INCOMPLETE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
OVER TWELVE BASINS THAT COULD BE
DEEMED TO PROBATIONARY AND THAT
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
WORKLOAD- THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
OF SIGMUND NOW REQUIRES THAT
ONCE THE BOARD DEEMS AT BASE AND
PROBATIONARY THERE IS THEY DO
HAVE TO WAIT AN ENTIRE YEAR
BEFORE THEY CAN START DEVELOPING
THE INTERIM PLAN TO MOVE THE
BASIN TOWARD SUSTAINABILITY AND
SO WITH THE EXISTING DELAYS
BUILT INTO THE STATURE WERE
CONCERNED THAT THESE PLANTS
WON'T BE READY UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND FOR COMMUNITIES ON THE
GROUND THIS COULD MEAN DELAY IN
GETTING RELIEF AND MOVEMENT
TOWARD SUSTAINABILITY THE APRIL
FINANCE LETTER NOTED THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILES COULD GO TRY THIS YEAR
ALONE AND IF WEARING CONTINUE
DROUGHT THAT NUMBER'S ONLY GOING
TO CONTINUE TO GET WORSE OVER
TIME- SO WE JUST ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT HOW THIS ACTION- TO
REJECT THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION
TODAY COULD NOT FURTHER DELAY
THAT TIME FRAME AND- ADD MORE
WORKLOAD TO THE TO THE BOARD'S
PROCESS. AND YOU'RE MINDFUL OF
THE SIX MILLION THAT WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO COMPLETE THAT THE
SEQUEL AND THE AT LEAST
PRESENTATION OF A MINIMUM AMOUNT
OF CHALLENGES THAT THAT THIS
AREA HAS HAD OKAY YEAH YEAH I
THINK THAT THAT THE FUNDING IS
HELPFUL- BUT IT'S JUST THAT
THERE'S A LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
AND AGAIN GIVEN THAT THERE IS A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
WAIT A YEAR TO START ON GETTING
THAT PLAN READY- WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW THAT THAT ADDS
POTENTIAL DELAY THERE BUT OUR
APPRECIATIVE OF THE RESOURCE AT
LEAST. THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS AND THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION. I WOULD WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION- FOR
PROACTIVELY ENGAGING IN
PROVIDING A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS YOU GUYS IN
YOUR DISCUSSIONS TODAY- HOWEVER
WE DO HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS AS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED. A
SPECIFICALLY AROUND- THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR TAKE BACK CREDIT.
THIS LIMITED TIME. WE BELIEVE
THIS PROPOSAL IS HAS SOME FLAWS.
I'M A WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
DIFFERENT IMPROVEMENTS OUT WITH
THE FUNDING IN THAT SPECIFIC
SPACE. I SPECIFICALLY ARE GOING
TOWARD SOME OF YOUR DISCUSSION
TODAY ABOUT RURAL AREAS-
INVESTING IN KEY AREAS. FOR NEW
CERTIFIED RECYCLING CENTERS
CERTIFIED PROCESSORS AND
ADDITIONAL METHODS OF COLLECTION
WE THINK THOSE FUNDS COULD BE
USED BETTER AND- ARE MORE WELL
SPENT AND THAT WAY. WE KNOW
THESE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS WILL
ALSO INCREASE THE STATE
RECYCLING RATE WHICH IS ONE OF
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM. AND
ALSO- PROVIDE CLEAN MATERIAL- TO
HELP WITH THE STATE'S MANDATED
RECYCLE CONTENT- IT FINALLY ALSO
ALONG WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED- TO HELP WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THIS BCP-
THAT IS FLEXIBLE STAFFING HOURS
HOURS OF OPERATION. ELECTRONIC
PAYMENTS TO CONSUMERS ONGOING
MAINTENANCE AND THEN CONSISTENT
COLLECTION METHODS OF MATERIALS
WHEN USING THE AUTOMATED
RECYCLING MACHINES WE THANK YOU
GUYS SO WE CAN. PLAN TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION I JUST MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. HELLO GOOD
MORNING- TERRA CAL SKIN MEMBERS-
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- THE THEIR CORE
MEMBERS ACTUALLY IT FROM ACROSS
THE STATE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
TODAY FOR THE GOVERNMENT
EDUCATION DAY. AND WE WOULD LOVE
FOR LEGISLATIVE OFFICES TO STOP
BY THE WEST LAWN TO SEE
DEMONSTRATION OF THE WORK THE
COURTS ARE DOING- INCLUDING YOUR
CYCLING WORK- THE CORES ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BCP. FROM
CAL RECYCLE PARTICULARLY THOSE
PIECES THAT ALLOW THE COURT TO
BUILD ON THEIR EXISTING
EXPERIENCE- IMPLEMENTING SOME OF
THE PILOT PROGRAMS. SO WE
APPRECIATE DIRECTOR WAGNER'S
CALL OUT FOR PRIORITIZING CALLS-
COURSE FOR THOSE MOBILE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS THAT ARE THAT
ARE BEING FUNDED- THERE'S AN
OVERLAP BETWEEN SOME OF THE
POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED LEGISLATIVELY THE
COURTS ARE IN SUPPORT OF AND
THIS B. C. P. SO WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION WORKING TOGETHER
TO IMPROVE WHAT WE ALL KNOW IS A
SYSTEM THAT'S IN NEED OF. SOME
SOME IMPROVEMENTS AND SOME
UPDATES- WE WOULD SUGGEST TO
FRIENDLY AMENDMENTS- THAT AREN'T
SPELLED OUT EXPLICITLY IN THE B.
C. P. SO FIRST THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AS WE
ALL KNOW IN THE MOBILE OF BUY
BACK CENTRES AND THEN
INSTALLATION OF AUTOMATIC
RECYCLING MACHINES WHICH-
DIRECTOR WAGNER ALSO REFERRED TO
AS REVERSE VENDING MACHINES. AND
LOCAL COURTS ARE CALLED OUT IN
THE B. C. P. BUT THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER LOCAL COURTS WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP STAFF THOSE
ACTIVITIES IN PARTICULAR. WE
THINK THAT THERE WILL NEED TO BE
SOME LOCAL CORE ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THOSE MOBILE PROGRAMS
THE A. R. M.'S AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT MIGHT BE
DEPLOYED- AND SECOND THERE WILL
LIKELY BE SOME TIME BETWEEN WHEN
THE BUDGET IS ENACTED IN ONE.
MOBILE PROGRAMS ARE UP AND
RUNNING. WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE
TO INCREASE IN FUNDING TO LOCAL
COURSE IN THE INTERIM TO.
INCREASE THEIR BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAMS
WILL THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
ARE BEING FOR THOSE MOBILE
PROGRAMS ARE. BEING DEPLOYED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN TODAY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION.
SPECIFICALLY TO TALK ABOUT THE
CAL RECYCLE- BCP WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR. FOR COMING
FORWARD WITH A PROPOSAL TO.
START TO LOOK AT HOW WE BETTER
USE- THE AMOUNT THAT IN RESERVE.
SIX HUNDRED MILLION IS A LOT OF
MONEY. HIGHNESS MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE USED TO IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM AND IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY RECYCLE. HOW
WE'RE NOT IN FAVOR OF THE
HUNDRED MILLION TO DOUBLE- THE
CRV- IN MANY OF THOSE AREAS THAT
ARE UNSERVED- THOSE ARE NOW
BEING SERVED BY GROCERY STORES.
AND MANY AREAS IN THE RURAL
AREAS OR SMALL GROCERY STORES.
SIMPLY CAN'T HANDLE HOW WHAT
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO DO NOW- AND
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO HANDLE THAT
INCREASED. POTENTIAL VOLUME-
THAT WOULD COME FROM THAT SHORT
TERM BENEFIT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
MONEY SHOULD BE. INVESTED IN IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE- AND WE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT FLEXIBILITY IN THE
CONVERSATION TODAY. YET THE BCP
IS REALLY SILO. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CERTAIN MONIES FOR RBM FOR
DROWNED OUT CERTAIN MONIES FOR
MOBILE WE THINK THOSE DECISIONS
SHOULD BE MADE ON A LOCAL LEVEL.
HOW TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY. FOR
CONVENIENCE TO HAPPEN IN THOSE
AREAS. WE ALSO HAD NO DISCUSSION
ABOUT CONVENIENCE- WE'RE STILL
WORKING OFF OF A HALF A MILE
RADIUS CIRCLE AROUND A GROCERY
STORE. THAT WAS WRITTEN THIRTY
YEARS AGO. OF THE 40% OR SO OF
UNSERVED ZONES WE'VE ONLY SEEN A
REDUCTION IN- RECYCLING BY EIGHT
TO TEN PERCENT. THOSE UNSERVED
ZONES WERE BEING OPERATED BY LOW
PERFORMING. RECYCLERS HOW CAN WE
ASSIST LOPER. RECYCLERS TO STAY
IN BUSINESS SO THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THAT CLEAN
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL. BACK THAT
NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION. THE DISCUSSION
DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED SOON
AROUND. RPM'S AT GROCERY STORES
IF AN RVM WORKS IS THERE A
BETTER LOCATION THAT PROVIDES
BETTER CONVENIENCE FOR
COMMUNITY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT AT HAPPENS AND THE ULTIMATE
GOAL OF INCREASING OUR RECYCLING
RATE SO WE LIKE THE IDEA OF
SPENDING THAT RESERVE DOWN THAT
MONEY NEEDS TO GET BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM. TO CREATE GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RECYCLING WE
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BETTER MOVE THAT MONEY FORWARD.
TO ACTUALLY OBTAIN THOSE GOALS
HAVE INCREASING THE RECYCLING
RATE THANK YOU. GREG HER ON
BEHALF OF THE CAN MANUFACTURERS
INSTITUTE FIRST TO. MISS CHARITY
LIKE TECHNOLOGY ARE CORRECT
THERE WERE TIMES DURING THE COVE
IT EMERGENCY THAT MATERIALS WERE
GOING DIRECTLY TO LANDFILLS- CAN
MANUFACTURERS INSTITUTE ACTUALLY
REACHED OUT SOME WASTE HAULERS
THAT WE'RE HAVING TO DO THAT- TO
SEE WHAT WE COULD DO TO
PARTICIPATE IN TRYING TO GET
THAT. MATERIAL BACK ONLINE-
TEMPORARILY STORED SO THAT CAN
BE PROCESSED AT A LATER TIME AND
THERE WERE- PUBLIC ARTICLES
ABOUT THAT AT THE TIME SO I
DON'T KNOW. WHO IS SEEM TO BE
REGIONAL THOUGH SO I'M NOT SURE
IT'S GOING TO SHOW UP IN ALL THE
WAYS CHARACTERIZATION STUDIES AS
A DIRECTOR WAS TALKING ABOUT.
BUT IT BUT IT DID OCCUR- CAN
FACTORIES INSTITUTE WOULDN'T
PRETTY MUCH LIKE TO ALIGN WITH-
THE COMMENTS AT THE- FROM THE L.
A. O. AND- MY PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUES AND- MANY OF YOU ON
THE COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
HAVE FORTY TWO PERCENT. OF ZONES
UNSERVED- IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
TO BE DOUBLING. THE DOING THE
CONSUMER CREDIT IDEA I MEAN YOU
HAVE. TO RULE MEMBERS UP HERE
BETTER. THAT THEIR- RESIDENTS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE TAKE BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT SO WE
HAVE TO GET THE INVESTMENT BACK
INTO- GETTING. RECYCLING CENTERS
UP AND RUNNING. THERE'S AS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT
STATUTORY ISSUES IT WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR ACTUALLY ON
BEHALF OF GROCERY STORES THAT
WOULD BRING RPM'S. YOU KNOW MAKE
IT MORE CONVENIENT FOR THEM- IT
DOESN'T DO ANY GOOD TO BRING
RPM'S OUT IF YOU DON'T TAKE CARE
OF SOME OF THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THERE
THAT MAKE IT REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR GROCERS ACTUALLY AGREED TO
EVEN PUT THEM UP IN PLACE. SO WE
THINK THERE ARE SOME OTHER
THINGS THAT REALLY NEED TO BE
WORK ON SO WE REALLY SUPPORT
THAT COMMITTEE HOLDING THIS
OPEN. OR REJECTING IT RIGHT NOW
TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS CAN
CONTINUE- BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT THE- DEPARTMENT IS ENGAGING
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD VERY GOOD LET'S
MODERATOR LET'S OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. AND I LAST THAT YOU PROP
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO PROVIDE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND- ANY OF
THE ISSUES BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
GO AHEAD MODERATOR OPEN THE
PHONE LINES AND HAVE US HAVE OUR
FIRST WITNESS WHO'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE CAN HEAR HERE IN ROME TWELVE
HUNDRED. I MEAN YOU CAN HEAR
THAT WITNESSES. YEAH. WHEN THIS
IS WE KNOW THAT THEIR HALF DOZEN
IF YOU IN LINE SO DON'T GO
ANYWHERE.
THE WAITING. ME YEAH I CAN HEAR
YOU NOW MODERATOR. OKAY THANK
YOU AND OUR FIRST QUESTION IS
FROM LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU BY TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU TO HEAR MY COUNTY AT
JEANNIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF MORE
WORDS- FIRST OFF REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK AND
OUTREACH TODAY ON MAKING SURE
THAT YOU NORTHEAST BOTTLE BILL
IT'S THE BEST WE CAN IT CAN BE
WE KNOW YOU'VE BEEN ACTIVE FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME- WHAT THE
GRIZZLIES THAT CLEAN RECYCLED
FEEDSTOCK ARE THE BUILDING
BLOCKS AT THE STATE LEVEL
PACKAGING. PACKAGING SOLUTION IT
IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION COMMITMENT TO
INVESTING IN THE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN RECENT YEARS
THE STATE HAS LOST MORE THAN 50%
OF ITS RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE-
MUCH OF ITS INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
A TAKE BACK MECHANISMS MOST
CONVENIENT FOR CONSUMERS THOUGH
WITH CONTAINERS. WERE
SUCCESSFULLY THWARTED AND
BREAKEVEN CONTAMINATION CLASS IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE BOY AT THE
WE SUPPORT BUDGET INVESTMENT IN
THE EXPANSION OF CLEAN
COLLECTION PROCESSES THIS
INCLUDES PROPERTIES THAT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CONSUMER
CAN BE A TAKE BACK BETTER- THAT
INCREASE SUPPLY AND REDUCE
BREAKING CONTAMINATION. ALSO
EFFORT TO INCENTIVIZE ARE
COMPELLED MORE RESPONSIBLE
SORTING THAT RESULT IN A CLEANER
FEEDSTOCK AND LASTLY EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT OR COMPENSATE FOR THE
HIGH COST OF BLACK
REMANUFACTURING OUR HOPE REALLY
IS THAT INVESTMENTS LIKE THOSE-
THAT I MENTIONED WILL INCREASE
THE RECYCLE BACK TO QUIET YOU
KNOW IN A WAY THAT WILL BENEFIT
ALL BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE HEARING TO RECYCLE
COLLECTED BY NEEDED FOR BEER AND
OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STAY ON OUR MUTUAL
SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING ALL THAT
THANKS AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU NEXT.
NINE FOUR PLEASE GO. GOOD MORE
MY NAME'S JOHN WITH WORLD ROAD
OF. WERE REALLY PLEASED TO THE
STATE ROPOSING TO SPEND
UNREDEEMED TO ACCESS TO CONSUMER
AND OPPORTUNITIES- TO THANK YOU
POWER CYCLE AND THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR CONSIDERING THIS
WELL WE THINK SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE REASONABLE WE
AGREE THAT MORE DETAILS ARE
NEEDED AND THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES SHOULD BE EXPLORED.
WE'RE SUPPORTING THE MOBILE AND
FIXED RECYCLING PROGRAMS IN
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
QUALITY ON TIME PAYMENTS AND
FORGIVABLE LOANS WE THINK THOSE
ALL MAKES SENSE WORKS BY THE
POTENTIAL POTENTIAL TO DEPLOY
REVERSE VENDING MACHINES BUT WE
BELIEVE THE POINT IS MACHINES AT
HIGH SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES WILL
REALLY MISS THE MARK AND COULD
INHIBIT USE OF THOSE FACILITIES.
BY MEMBERS OF THE GENERAL
PUBLIC- MY BACK THE ENVELOPE
CALCULATIONS IS FOR MOST HIGH
SCHOOL THAT WOULD EQUAL AN
INVESTMENT OF ABOUT FIVE DOLLARS
PER KID AT THE HIGH SCHOOL WHEN
THERE AREN'T ADEQUATE REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES ANOTHER IS THAT
THE STATE. WE ALSO HAVE STRONG
MISGIVINGS ABOUT DOUBLING THE
REFUND PAID TO CONSUMERS BECAUSE
IT ONLY LASTS A VERY I'M IN
COULD BE EXACT BY THE TIME WE
GET REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES OUT
TO THOSE WHO DON'T HAPPEN TODAY
SO WE THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
MERIT AND AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED NEGOTIATIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS- AND ARE
ENCOURAGED WITH WHERE THIS IS
GOING THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
. THE NEXT QUITE. IS FROM NINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
CLARY AND I'M A CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR CLEAN WATER ACTION
SPEAKING ON ISSUES THAT. ARE OF
THE NATION'S STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE PETITION PROPOSED THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO ADDRESS
POTENTIALLY DOZENS OF INADEQUATE
SIGNAL PLANS BUT WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ACCEPT THE BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE PROVIDING
SECRET CONNECTION FOR THE
ENTERPRISE. THE BOARD CENTER
PLANTS WE PLACE ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS PLAN FOR THE BEEN FOUNDED
ADEQUATE AND DELAY OR FAILURE TO
IMPLEMENT THESE INSURANCE PLANS
RESULT IN NO ACTION BEING TAKEN
LAST WEEK WAS CONDUCTED THESE
SPACES BRING CRITICAL OVER
DRAFTED LAST YEAR HUNDRED WELLS
WENT DRY EVERY YEAR THAT NO
ACTION IS TAKEN EXTENT THAT
UNTENABLE SITUATION AS MUCH AS I
RESPECT I THINK WHAT. THE
PROPOSED ACTION WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITE EFFECT THAT IS INTENDED
BY THE APPLICATION OF THE
STATUTE SO WE URGE YOU. TO
ACCEPT THAT TRAILER LANGUAGE IN. THE POSITION THANK YOU. THE
NEXT. IS FROM ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING ANNOUNCING
OPEN FROM THE CONTAINER
RECYCLING INSTITUTE I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ON ISSUE NINE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING. WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO SEE THE
CONVERSATION THE LEGISLATURE
TURN TOWARD BOTH PROPOSALS AND
IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING FOR REAL
PROGRAM. THEORIZE NINE OF THE
PPP HAS WRITTEN. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNE TO MAKE HEALTH AVERAGE
CONTAIN RECYCLING PROGRAM
INVOLVED CLASS PROGRAM. ANYTHING
AT THE MAGNITUDE REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE OF THE PROBLEM
STRATEGICAL SETTING ESTABLISH OF
METRIC PLAN DEVELOPMENT
MONITORING AND REPORTING AND
METRICS THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR RECYCLING CREDIT.
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC AND
WOULD CREATE A GREAT DEAL OF
DESTRUCTION THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM WOULD DO NOTHING. FOR
CONSUMERS AND RECYCLING DOESN'T.
THE MILLION IN Q. I. P. ALSO
PROBLEMATIC PERFECT FOR ARE
ALREADY TURNED OVERPAID. MORE IN
THE TO ENSURE MATERIAL TO HIKE.
OUR LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE
WRECKED. FOR MODERN AND
REFORMING THE PROGRAM EIGHTEEN
TWENTY EQUITY FOR CONSUMERS.
FIVE PREVENTION IN THE-
ALIGNMENT OF CONTENT WITH
OUTCOMES IMPROVEMENT OF MY AND
COURSE. AND MODERNIZATION OF THE
PHYSICAL AND ELECTRONIC
OPERATION OF THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'VE- THE NEXT
COMMENT IS THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER GET HOUSE ON
BEHALF OF THE WATER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING FOR A
POSITION TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO ASSIST IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BIG MONEY
PARTICULARLY WITH THE NUMEROUS
INADEQUATE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED PARCEL
PICK WITH THEM SETTING ASIDE THE
PLANNING. TO ALLOW THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO STAND TRACK WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE
THANK YOU. NEXT THE NEXT
COMMENTED LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR OPEN. HELLO I CAN HEAR
YOU GO HEAD- MY NAME- HERE A
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
NATALIE CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP PROBLEMS WILL BEGIN
ON ISSUE SIX. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THAT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD BE GIVEN
BECAUSE FUNCTION FOR THEIR
ENGINE FRANCE WHEN YOU THINK
WORKING ON THEIR GST THEY WERE
GETTING SICK WHAT FUNCTION IN TO
BE. AND NEXT THE LIMITS. THE
NINETEEN THE FUNCTIONS OF BOARD
WILL MOVING FORWARD TO THINK OF
A SOLUTION FOR OUR- WHICH
BECOMING INCREASE CRITICAL AS WE
FURTHER DROUGHT JEFF ISN'T TO
SIMPLE POLICY TO PROTECT WATER
AND THAT'S YOUR UNCLE CONTINUE
SIX. OVER PUMP ARE GROUNDWATER
WE URGE YOU SIX THE CHANGE.
THANK YOU. MAX AND THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE YOU AT TIME RIGHT THEM
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING BRING
BACK TO A MAN. OF THE ON THE
VOTE ONLY. WE HAVE ISSUES ONE
TWO AND FIVE. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION CENTER REQUIRE. THERE'S A
MOTION AND THIS IS TO VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ISSUES ONE TWO AND FIVE
PLEASE OPEN ROLE RIGHT CASKEY HI
MY CASKEY HI. DALY NO. FOLLOWING
UP. MCGUIRE REQUIRE HIGH STERN
FIVE STERN AYE FOUR ZERO THREE
THREE I'M SORRY THREE ONE THIRTY
THREE ONE THOSE- MATTERS ARE
PROOF ON THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDARS THE REMAINING ISSUES
THREE FOUR AND SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MISS ROY. MY CASKEY I
REQUEST THE AYE DALY. THE ONLY
NOT VOTING. REQUIRE THE GRANT
HIGH STERN FIVE STERN HIGH.
THREE ZERO THERE'S THREE ZERO
THAT THOSE MATTERS ARE PROOF CAN
END THEIR DISCUSSION ITEMS WE
HAVE ISSUE NINE- IS THERE A
MOTION CENTER DOLLY THIS MOTION
BY SENATOR DOLLY- THIS IS THE
STAFFORD CONDITION IS TO
REJECTED ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY HI MY COUNTY HIGH
SELLING. FIVE MILLION NINE
MCGUIRE. THE GRANT CURRENT.
THIRTY NINE FOUR ZERO. IF FORCED
THAT- MATT IT IS- STAFFORD
CONDITIONS APPROVED ALL RIGHT I
THANK YOU ALL ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PUBLIC HEARING TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD THANK YOU HONORED PRIEST
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY WHO
PEERED HERE. BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND PERSON WE CONCLUDE
WE HAVE CONCLUDED TODAY'S AGENDA
THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER.